Hello,
hello, hello, I was just about to say about the...
About the... Josh show, but...
I was told that it's sold out already.
There will be more tickets tomorrow.
for the people that did not that did not do the pre-sale
to be fair it's a very very small venue and and and and
there are streaming tickets so if you wanted to go to if you
wanted to watch the jazz just 3D live, then those are
options too!
Hopefully!
Yeah, it's very, very, very, very small.
I apologize, it's kind of...
But also, I was not quite sure how well tickets would go
Because it's not like a typical idol show.
But, uh...
Thank you!
Oh, Super Chats are still off.
I forgot.
Wait, let me see.
We can turn the back on.
I forgot about it.
Okay, this should be good, though.
But thank
you!
Thank you!
If you could not get a ticket, I'm so sorry!
Hopefully I can do another one in the future.
I mean, if this one...
Has the...
Oh, wait.
One second.
Sorry, I'm getting pinged about things.
Oh.
How do you get the one?
I didn't have a new year's dream but I had a dream today you
apparently bought a 70k yen fuamoko suitcase 70k yen how
much is that like 7,000 dollars or something well I guess a
little less depending on the yen wait 70k seven how How many
numbers is that?
Seven?
Zero?
Bore?
Wait.
How many zeros is it?
I'm off by a zero.
Oh, it's like a...
Oh!
It's like...
Actually, I feel like that's a...
That seems like I'm kind of...
normal price for that like a suitcase that is that is a
themed like that finally hot dogs it would be like 500 usd
and right now in january 2nd 2026
see you in la meantime i can't wait for a jazzy valentine's
day bro thank you thank you thank you
and i boo speckles thank you yeah i think a branded suitcase
for 500 ish ish pretty normal i think so too right or am i
am i insane not that i would i mean oh sorry let me finish
reading and a giant freaky phantom thief handbag also
congrats on your concert selling out in two minutes mint i
don't think it will sell out phantom i didn't know because
it's not like a regular concert.
It's jazz.
Not everybody likes jazz.
Not everybody's going to want to go.
Wow, thank you so much for the walk.
I was unable to send one last stream, but how many do you
hear me?
Don't appreciate it.
All that you do and everything you will do.
This coming year.
Thank you.
Jeff, congrats on getting a ticket.
Okay, I'll see you though.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
But everyone likes you, Minto.
That's not true.
That's impossible.
It's impossible for everybody to like somebody.
Wait, for everybody to like one person.
For one shot.
Reason to stay up to 1 a.m.
No, go to sleep.
The VOD will be there.
You like jazz.
It's going to be an extremely jazzy show.
I think I finalized songs yesterday even.
yeah.
We'll try to get jazz tickets tomorrow.
Good luck.
I like jazz, but Wheelie Jack will always be my favorite.
This is a transform.
Warmer's joke.
Shut up, me.
Happy New Year!
Extreme jazz, gold!
So...
Ryan, Ryan,
Spent the past two years being a lurker, so one of my New
Year's resolutions is be more active in chat!
Also getting more hours, so I might have to be Vodgang for a
couple of streams.
More hours?
Sounds good though.
That's...
You...
Bake that bread!
Thank you though!
Thank you!
Thank you everybody.
Lurker turned chatter.
Wow!
Bake that bread.
Bake it.
I hope it's cinnamon raisin bread.
Oh yeah.
That sounds like the goods.
Cinnamon raisin bread.
bread.
I want some right now.
Can't stick around.
I'm not doing well.
Brandon!
No!
Please.
Please feel better.
Are there any chances of online merch for the jazz show?
Jazz concert?
Um, I believe so.
I believe so.
The sentinel will be putting it up, but I will double check.
Managed to get a GA ticket.
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
What are the Aibu's favorite mainstreams of 2025?
Mine include Dredge?
Metal Gear?
Nancy Drew?
Mystery of the Druids?
Thank goodness you're here in the legendary jazz karaoke.
Yeah!
I...
For the jazz show even.
Some songs that I sung before in jazz karaoke will be sung
again and some new songs as well.
So...
Yes, yes, yes.
Journey.
Nancy Drew's in the public domain now apparently.
What?
Nancy Drew is that old?
The Nancy Drew's dreams were great.
Maybe I should play another one.
It was so funny though.
Brace for Nancy Drew horror media.
But, like, it's kind of already set up for that, no?
I mean, it's just like a Scooby-Doo.
Guys, I was thinking.
I played this game.
How did I move around?
How?
How did I move?
How did I walk around?
Did I use my regular keyboard?
How did I do that?
Controller!
I had to plug in my controller.
Greetings from Holland!
Oh my gosh.
1am here.
Just wanted to say how inspiring you've been.
I've stayed dedicated to fitness for 8 plus months.
Thanks to you.
Like a little Jiminy cricket pushing me on.
You and the community are all amazing.
Thanks for inspiring so many.
Thank you!
Oh my gosh.
David, thank you for the awesome.
super and congratulations 8 plus months that's crazy that's
crazy thank you thank
you yes well anyway yes managed to snipe a VIP ticket Loki
shaking with adrenaline I always am like that with tickets
though it scares me I've actually some people do you guys I
don't like the rush of like trying to get to trying to be
online for like an item that's like limited stock or tickets
or something it freaks me out i don't like it at all mcmack
thank you mint was a jazz club regular i'd go every night
because i'll try my luck again tomorrow good luck good luck
and burpee thank you
and combo thank you thanks for the hot dog it's too
stressful right I feel like I don't get like that.
I mean, maybe you get the adrenaline.
Adrenaline.
Wait, now I can't say it properly.
Couple.
Yeah, there will still be something more tomorrow.
I will be honest.
It's a very, very small amount tomorrow.
But there was also the streaming tickets though.
Adrenaline.
Why was I saying that word?
Wait.
Why was I saying the...
The rush.
Of a ticket.
When you get tickets for a show, Yeah.
Because I had a I had the rush for the tickets.
Yeah, but I had something I wanted to say.
Oh, man.
I had something I wanted to say.
I had something that I wanted to do declare.
Happy New Year, Mito!
Hoping!
This new year, I can be less Vodgang and more proud.
present.
Oh, Glister.
Oh, he's in any form by your side.
Thank you.
Congrats for the sold-out.
Jazzy Minky love you so much.
Love you!
I do declare that I don't like it.
But then at the same time, for like lottery stuff, I know
it's technically more fair, but at the same time, I'm always
like I feel like I'm like, my luck is so bad.
I've never felt confident in a lottery.
This is What was that Saul Goodman world, Minto?
Was it your hubby's face?
So let's talk about the New Year's.
Oh, happy new year, everybody.
I haven't seen you since last year.
I bet you haven't heard that joke before ever.
And...
New mirror, minto.
Thank you, Fokura.
Can I recommend you three songs?
Oh, thank you.
Check them out.
Wow, so clever.
You could say I'm the entertainer of all time.
If you have not watched the 3D sloppy...
3D, the VR chat.
It's technically 3D, but VR chat.
Sloppy Sisters collab on Doki Bird Channel.
Lithuania!
This is my first time watching a live stream.
Welcome!
Wait, why are we having so many people from, like, Europe
today?
This is crazy.
Hi.
Hello!
Wow, go to sleep!
But, um, the stream was so funny.
I still am having issues with my VR chat for anyone curious.
And if, uh, basically, last time I tried to do a VR chat
stream, My audio has not been coming out of my headset.
So I can't hear anything.
I have to turn on my computer speakers for me to do
anything, which is quite annoying.
And then I'm also having issues with just, I guess, my VR
chat account in general because I wasn't able to...
I wasn't able to add anybody as a friend or send anybody.
anything or receive anything it was crazy um was not lucky
enough certain ticket vendor hate i'm sorry congratulations
to all the ibusu made it probably better for my wallet not
to fly across half the country that's thinking on the bright
side thank you so much brother thank you for trying
organizer thank you for the super chat thank you john thank
you for the super chat looking forward to the concert, I
will dress for the occasion.
Even if I could only get streaming tickets.
Volume 0, thank you.
Managed to get a ticket.
Mercurially, thank you!
Favorite memory from last year I played as Oslo and
mint-abanded I undress.
Have you tried using VR chat on your laptop to A-B test the
issues?
Well, I don't think I could use my headset, my VR headset on
my laptop but I've tried like uninstalling the steam VR
software and reinstalling and I've if there is a reddit
thread about it I have tried it the VR chat issues I'm not
so concerned about because I mean if I have to make another
VR chat account that's no biggie but you know the VR audio
issues are a It was a pretty big deal to me.
But it was just, I felt so bad because so many things were
scuffed during the stream because of me.
I couldn't go to the world because I couldn't see their
portals.
And that's also why I didn't stream my POV because I was
like, it's gonna be maybe hellish for anybody watching
because it will just be me having issues the whole time.
So I thought maybe it'll be fine if it's only Doki.
And I think Snuffy was streaming as well.
So Doki, Snuffy, POV.
But I was waiting for Doki to come pick me up for anybody
curious.
And I was like, I wonder if there's any Breaking Bad World.
Which is a completely stupid thing to think.
Because of course there's a Breaking Bad World.
And Happy New Year's everybody and us.
Happy New Year!
And I just saw the world was called Saul Goodman.
I don't think it had anything else called that.
And I just went in and everything was...
I mean, you saw how the world was.
And it was even worse in person.
Like with my own two eyes.
And I was like, I wasn't sure if Doki would...
would come looking for me or not.
So I just kind of was sitting in there and admiring the
view.
It was so loud.
I passed out halfway through and woke up to the Saul Goodman
verse and just figured I was still asleep.
Also, RS Nation, thank you!
Wow on a plane?
Holy cow!
Wow, the plane must have amazing internet.
Thank you so much, see you there!
But I'm really glad that it ended up being a funny moment
for everybody.
Honestly, like the whole chain of events is just so funny.
Like Doki going back to the fishing world and being like
Mint Mint and then her checking where I'm at and she's like
what why the heck is she us?
And then her joining the world she's like Oh my god!
And then...
And then running around being like, Pirate!
Where are you?
And then I didn't know that you could see me in the first
couple...
Okay.
Doki asked me later.
She was like, didn't you hear me calling out to you?
This goes back to my audio issues.
If anybody was talking very low, I could not hear them.
Because I was too afraid of turning my speaker.
up and receive it you guys receiving feedback because you
know you would hear it would pick up be picked up by my
headset mic or something and so I couldn't hear it so the
music was so loud the music was so loud she was just a
little bit far away you know just far enough I had no idea
She was there.
I've had the VR audio thing before.
Is the output set to the right device when it's on?
You can set it by left-clicking the speaker in the system
tray and expanding the menu.
Yeah, see, that's the funny thing.
It doesn't show up in the menu.
Yeah.
I've gone through a bajillion things.
Honestly, Doki was like, you might need to buy a new
headset.
And I'm like...
A Valve Index is...
thousand dollars like and i know i've had it for like i've
had it for many years now at this point i bought it when i
first debuted ish so i've had it for a very very long time
but it's crazy expensive i can't just be dropping that like
like you know i don't know could wait for the new valve vr
set That's what I think I might do.
I'm not gonna lie.
Have you talked to that VR chat rep person Doki recommended
yet?
Oh, no, not yet.
But I don't think they'll be able to help with the headset.
I think they can only help with VR chat.
Doki says that maybe I accidentally dropped it.
And that some...
But I didn't.
I take care of my things.
And...
Um...
I think, uh...
It...
What's the word?
I think it would still pick up, right?
Like, I feel like it would still pick up in the sound
settings under, like, output.
I feel like it would still show up there, even if, like, the
speakers were...
Or, like, the thing itself were broken.
Hmm.
Yeah, so...
I...
I seriously, you guys, I have tried everything.
There is not...
A Reddit thread that I have not gone through.
There is not a YouTube tutorial that I have not tried.
I have literally tried everything.
I don't think a VR chat representative will be able to help
me with it.
I think they can help me with my VR chat account.
But I don't even have their information, so.
But everything else is so cool and your models are super
cute.
Yeah!
I had so much fun.
Don't get me wrong.
I had a super...
super duper amount of fun.
I'm glad that I could take everybody on the planes and and
and Saul Goodman World.
I actually went to another Breaking Bad World where it was
like a parkour and I was doing that for quite a bit of time
too while I was waiting for them to come and find me.
Doki was working on something.
And I was like, la la la.
Breaking Bad Parkour
maybe next time i do vr chat um sound issues be damned i
mean it would outputs for you guys you guys would be able to
hear it so make you enjoy welcome back thank you thank you
thank you
doki running around and chatting for you with the heads is
exactly how i didn't know i wanted to start the new year it
was so funny oh i'm glad that i'm glad it could be a good
first memory but i feel like i felt i felt you know that it
was a pretty good like uh it was a good start to the year
maybe so i'm quite hopeful about having lots of fun
throughout the year so
I'm quite hopeful.
But I was getting so tired by the end of it.
I was like, I'm just gonna lay down.
And the back of the VR headset has like a big old cushion.
So it felt like a pillow.
And I was like starting to fall asleep for real.
So for the new VR headset, do you sell a kidney or one of
your RAM sticks?
I think YouTube censors kidney or RAM.
Clearly they're equally horrific.
No!
Not my RAM!
Have you tried throwing it into a pond and seeing if some
nice pond lady comes up and offers you a silver or gold
version of it?
Of my VR headset, I could try.
And I'll say, no.
No, ma'am.
I want the original.
And she'll be like, you have a good heart.
Or you have heard this story before.
And then I'll get it for free.
but yeah I just feel like I don't know like obviously I use
my VR but I don't use it enough to where I feel like I can
justify dropping another $1,000 on it
I'm still thinking about it when is the next VR steam VR
thing planning planning to come out I don't know.
Steam VR...
Not Steam VR.
Steam VR headset.
It's like not gonna be called a Valve.
Was it the Steam frame?
Is that it?
March!
No way!
That's so soon!
Wait, I'm clicking on this link.
Steam frame!
Wait.
It looks nice.
Is it cordless?
Oh my gosh, it is!
That's huge!
If I got this, I would play Half-Life Alex.
Or maybe I'd be scared too, I don't know.
Whoa, even the controllers are all new and everything.
It kind of looks like those Apple goggles.
What were those called?
Would that mean lag though?
I don't know, that's a good point.
My only problem is they get VR sickness, like, whoa.
No, I get it though, I get it.
Depending on the game, some games are really terrible.
The Apple Vision.
Is that the thing?
Apple Vision.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm gonna become one of those people walking around, wearing
it, and I'm gonna have my arms swiping around.
I'm gonna become one of those people walking down.
Jarvis Cancel my meeting I'm going to brunch Do people still
wear these?
I feel like they were such a fad
I'm wow Oh my gosh there's like Wait a second I have to show
you guys the website for this Steam frame Wait hold on one
second I gotta show you.
We're gonna take a quick detour.
Quick detour, quick detour.
Oh, that was my controller disconnecting.
Don't mind.
Okay, so they're like, this is it.
This is the steam frame, right?
I'm minding.
Don't mind.
See, it looks really nice, though.
It looks so small.
Well, you can't tell right now, but it looks...
like it'll fit it'll be not so heavy because the valve index
is like a million bricks on my head right now it looks very
small and i don't know how i feel about the these though but
look how small it is wow and then and then that's gonna be
me what game is this that's not half-life is it that's
Jarvis, make Minto trip on a cartoon banana peel.
That's me.
Oh, it is Half-Life.
I could tell.
Grandma.
Grandma is playing the VR.
I think grandma would literally get psychosis from that.
And then, oh, let's see.
High quality streaming.
Streaming first experience.
That's what I do.
Streaming can be highly variable, so we prioritize.
making steam frame a stable, high-quality streaming
experience.
I believe the words on the screen.
You know that the tallest building on earth is...
Word Khalifa.
With 828 meters, but it's still not enough to reach your
cuteness level.
Stoven.
I don't know if I said that right, though.
Seamless audio experience.
Currently, I have no audio experience.
an upgrade.
Me?
That's literally me?
Grandma!
Look, it looks so small.
Okay, what I wanted to show you...
Actually, I don't remember.
Oh, the...
Wait.
Was it...
Why don't you just get on your PC?
Stop.
Don't bother me.
I'm playing game in VR.
is it light though let's see does it say how heavy it is oh
no we'll never get one wait why does the headset need
storage wait do I have to get the 1 terabyte headset ref ref
Ram!
How heavy are you?
Oh wait!
G.
440 G.
Wait, why is the head strap so heavy?
You can load games on it.
Oh!
I see, I see.
It's a standalone device?
Wait, that's kind of insane.
I wonder how heavy the valve index is, though.
One replaceable double A battery.
Wait, what?
They're not...
They're not chargeable?
It's double A battery?
Wait, what?
For the controller?
Yeah, but like, they're not like...
No way.
I'm gonna have to buy batteries for it.
Mickey, Mickey, Mickey, Mickey.
I know!
I choked on my ectoplasm!
Happy New Year!
Don't have to further nudge you towards replacing hardware
if you need to!
It's good to be frugal but the frustration is not worth your
time if it's busted.
Time wasted!
Time wasted on troubleshooting!
That is time you can spend on literally anything else.
Thank you!
So you can swap it if it dies in the middle of a game.
I just plug in my controller.
I had to do that for the VR collab.
One of my controllers was literally plugged in the whole
time.
I think it's just strange that we...
Are doing...
Batteries.
Like, I guess I could get rechargeable batteries, but I
still feel like it's a pain in the booty.
It's cool to see that Barry became the fourth member of
Densitou.exe and Barrybook.
I didn't expect that at all.
I'm confused.
Where did that come from?
Why is Barry in Densitou?
Why don't we switch?
What if I go to Beasties?
I think I'm more Monster Girl than she is.
She made a joke.
She just made it.
interesting what the hell
I'm a monster girl too Eric I got a new bike for Christmas
and one of my goals this year is to get in better shape with
it and go many places with it wish me luck I hope 2026 is a
great year for you too good luck oh my gosh
biking sound oh my gosh I was just thinking that like okay
so recently hold on let me let me okay we're done looking at
the, we're done looking at this guy, even though he's so
cute.
It's pretty cute, I'm not gonna lie.
Um, but, uh, I was talking to a friend the other day, and I
was like, I've seen so many electric bikes recently.
Um, like I saw a kid on an electric bike, and I've just seen
more of them recently, and I'm like, honestly, you know, I'm
kind of here for it.
I'm here for the electric bike era.
Because it's like...
It's like...
You know, they...
I bet it's so much...
It's like you can get to a place so fast.
And you're still biking.
So you're getting a little bit of exercise at least.
And they're not as scary as like a scooter, I feel.
Because scooters, I hear that people will like hit a weird
bump.
And they'll be going really fast on them.
And hit a bump.
And like...
You know, like that.
And...
Um...
I don't know...
They're kind of banned where I am because of the fire hazard
quality.
Wait, there's a fire hazard!
Scooters are a dentist's best friend.
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Everyone will say they will still bike and end up only using
the engine.
Ah, that's fair.
I mean...
But...
kind of sketchy since they're fast and don't have good
breaks but if we if we kept working towards it i feel like
there's such a good alternative you know i don't know as
long as people aren't stupid but that's asking a lot isn't
it that's asking me for so much but i just think it's not so
much nicer because sometimes i don't want to i want a bike i
don't want to drive way too much I like thinking about
bikes.
The e-bike batteries can explode or catch fire while
charging.
Holy moly!
That's scary.
Can't you fly?
I can float.
I can't fly.
I'm not a bird.
That would take, like, so much of my energy to fly.
This is not a joke.
The guy who invented the segue...
Died riding a segue off a cliff to demonstrate how safe they
are and how fast they can stop.
That's not a joke.
Wait, that's not real.
I'm going to look it up.
Death of the segue.
Segway company owner rides scooter off cliff, comma dies.
It's not funny.
He puts a headline.
It's just...
I just read the headline, you guys!
That's what it says!
Wow, this happened so long ago.
This happened in 2010!
In two- Jimmy Heseldon.
In 2009, he bought Segway Inc.
He died in 2010 from injuries.
Sustained falling from a cliff while riding his own Segway.
You know, I have to give him credit.
He really trusted in his own product.
Would you take Otacon on your e-bike?
Oh, yeah.
Holy moly.
Command was committed to the bit.
Like, he really believed in his product.
Unfortunately, that's so sad, though, that, like, nah, he
just bought the company.
I mean, it did, but, like, He still did that demonstration
because he thought that he would not die.
So it's not the inventor, though.
It's just the owner that, the person that owned the company
at the time.
May the kamiyoshi protect my travels, Honda gang.
May the kamiyoshi protect your travels.
Sorry, I'm coughing so much today.
I'm going to take another sip.
I've never seen a segue though outside of a mall and outside
of those like sometimes some cities did segue tours.
Those are the only two times I've never seen someone like a
like a private segue user.
I've never seen what IRL.
Yeah yeah I feel like it no.
Never seen.
Anyway I think I've I hope you guys had a wonderful new year
welcoming welcoming of of the new year I hope it was lots of
fun for you guys so and thanks for coming back thanks for
being here with me!
Thank you!
Welcome back to OneShot!
Let me turn on my control- My controller is turned on.
Today we're playing New Game Plus.
Nico feels uneasy.
Today we're playing New Game Plus of the game to get the
true ending.
And...
Yeah!
This is not our one shot.
This is our two shot.
New Year's was fun with you and Sloppy Sisters and thank you
for the New Year's post.
Of course!
Oh, I wanted to post it earlier.
I wanted to post it so much earlier, but I was struggling
you guys with the picture.
I feel still, like, so...
I saw a post on my timeline that was, like, someone who...
Um... Who...
Kind of like, they weren't tracing or anything, don't get me
wrong, but they were looking at a picture and then, like,
trying to draw the same exact picture.
And theirs turned out, like, really kind of funky.
Like, it was a Takane from Idol Master.
Yeah, like, a reference.
But they were trying to do it one for one, you know.
And they were like, they were like, man, like, the original
is so cute, but mine turned out so funky.
And, um, even though I was, like, looking and trying to
emulate the same exact everything.
Um, and I, I've, I've, I have tried doing that to kind of,
like, reference, like, a pose or something and be like, oh,
maybe, like, I draw, I've drawn so much more than I've
posted.
Yeah, it's not weird for practicing at all.
No, no, I'm not trying to say, I'm not trying to, um, uh,
I'm not trying to like shame the guy or anything.
What I was trying to say is that the same thing has happened
to me where I'll look at a picture and in my brain I'm like,
yeah, this is pretty simple.
Like it'll even be like a simple sketch.
And I'll be like, this is pretty simple.
I think I can, you know, kind of recreate this with my own
way.
And then I'll try it and I'll be like, why does this look so
bad?
Why?
I'm here.
I know it's all part of the process, but it's still like...
Ah!
Many such cases.
It's just, you know...
I've always obviously had an appreciation for artists and
everything.
It's just like, oh my gosh, it feels so daunting.
I'm like, you know, I see people that can do backgrounds and
this and that and amazing.
stuff and I'm like you know I'm not not trying to become
like a professional level or anything but I would like to
get pretty decent but thank you everybody who thinks my art
is is cute so far thank you it's hard when you know a lot
about art but aren't practiced enough to do it yourself yeah
I don't all i get really scared about like learning coloring
techniques and stuff that stuff that's something i have zero
knowledge about like i can do it but like i'm i see like
people's people's like time lapses and things and i'm like
what are you doing how'd you do that so robot what's left of
a robot so i'm guessing i kind of do the same thing before
and we go to that building over here one step at a time like
you've done so far super cute and you'll only grow i don't
know i've been like kind of picky about what i post so i'll
try to draw something and then erase erase erase i try to
draw something erase erase erase erase i try i had a
completely different picture drawn for the new year for the
new year letter and then I I said thank you, Duargo, thank
you and then I totally scrapped it so I was like, no yeah,
it's totally normal that's how it goes, yeah ah, that light
bulb you are here, me?
yes, welcome to our world friend I am most humbled by your
presence, yes thanks sorry, I'm a little lost wait, is this
all This is all the same dialogue, but I don't want to skip
anything because I'm nervous that maybe Nico will be like
something else, you know?
That's how it goes.
I would want to see the ones that you scrapped too.
No, I'm too self-conscious.
I'm too self-conscious.
May I ask how you arrived here?
I'm not sure.
I woke up in this weird house.
Uh, uh, it was really dark.
Oh, so you woke up in an unfamiliar dark location.
Mm-hmm.
Just as my prophecy foretold, yes.
You are the savior we have been waiting for.
Jasmine!
Welcome to Mambusha, thank you.
Maybe just not narrate it if it's old.
Maybe.
Save the world from eternal darkness.
I'll skip it a little bit.
Vital information.
Please ask me anything.
Uh, can you tell me about...
About Adminto!
That one's new.
When I woke up in that house, for some reason I called out a
name, Adminto.
Commander Muffin!
Welcome to Bevbusha.
Oh my gosh, I love your profile picture.
I love Suboyants.
They're so cute.
Adminto is very stinky.
Hey!
I showered this morning.
I'm not sure why I did that.
But then I saw it on a computer, too.
Ah, that would be our god.
Oh, right.
I think I feel like I remember something about that.
You do?
But wait, did you not just arrive here?
I was the one who was supposed to inform you of that.
So how did you know?
Um, it just made sense, I guess.
Ah, have you already contacted Adminto then?
Nope.
I just have to close my eyes and focus, right?
I am here, Nico.
Hey, Admito.
God?
This is going to sound weird, but...
Have we met before?
Do I tell the truth?
Hmm.
I'll say yes.
Yes.
But I don't know who you are, though.
It's just a weird feeling that I have.
I'm just being silly, aren't I?
Would you lie to Nico?
No.
Sorry.
But it's nice to meet you, Adminto.
My name is Nico.
I know.
I just contacted Adminto, yeah?
Do not be afraid to ask Adminto for assistance.
You are the Messiah, after all.
Can you tell me...
I think we were good with these.
Oh, wait.
I think I have to do all of them.
The world, everything's so dark.
The world is divided into three regions, apparently.
Going to the tower.
In the outpost we gotta get a map.
The light bulb.
The new sun is the light bulb.
Light went out.
The new sun you restored at the tower.
Cool, cool, cool.
Nico is so cute.
I know.
That looks pretty far off.
So begins your pilgrimage.
If the sun shatters, the world will end in an instant.
Going home.
I want to go home.
Your mission is to save our world.
Just as my mission is to tell you about our world.
Okay, I think that's all I have to ask for now.
Excellent, I wish you luck.
Alright, let's grab our map.
Which is...
Those are all probably all the same too, right?
I think so.
Oh, we need the battery.
Love the sound of the footprints.
Oh, wait.
There it is.
Over there.
This is the law of robots.
Our map.
Of the world.
Oh, wait.
Just kidding.
We didn't get a map of the world.
What were they thinking of that?
We needed a map.
Okay.
this should still be the same.
If anybody has played this game and I have missed something,
feel free to yell at me.
It won't turn on.
Okay.
The tippy taps.
I know they're so satisfying.
It's like...
I love it.
I never thought of myself as a big ASMR person, but the more
I hear like a...
It sounds really nice.
Heh heh.
Hojo danjo!
Welcome to Membuship.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
Minto ASMR.
Should I do ASMR again?
I don't know though.
I can't take it seriously when I do it.
I can't remember where I got that pipe from.
Oh wait!
Do you remember the code?
Doesn't have to be serious.
I've got to try out, like, an RP.
A roleplay.
ASMR.
But I don't know what.
Kind.
Babycore!
Thanks for the gift.
Maybe it's in the documents folder still.
Oh, it might be.
Wait, maybe.
We could really speedrun some of this.
Wait, what's over here?
I haven't been over here yet.
I haven't been here before.
I don't remember any of this.
Gas.
Cannot breathe.
It hurts to breathe.
Do you want to open some missions for scripts?
That sounds dangerous.
Guys, you're going to make me say some real freaky things.
Maybe I should try just a regular ASM.
modifiers.
Since I feel a little self-conscious when I do them.
Oh,
it was Crow Country that I was thinking of that I needed the
maps.
I was like, there was a game that I played recently where I
did not know where to go ever, and I needed maps for stuff.
Crow Country.
This seems like... Okay, this did loop, okay.
Very cool.
What about this one?
ever read this?
No, I don't remember.
The sun will not return and the abyss is calling my name.
I'm sorry, everyone, for choosing to leave behind the
darkness.
Choosing to leave before the darkness suffocates us all.
I love how you still have shortcuts for Harvester and
Mystery of the Druids on your desktop.
Yeah!
I do.
That one was not such a nice one.
I think I think we get the steel pipe from in here, right?
The light bulb.
RP ASMR, you mean like clumsy boyfriend sinks cruise ship
killing thousands of ASMR?
I would totally listen to a silly otaku gets lost and
Aki-bum falls downstairs into a haunted makeup ASMR.
That sounds like a realistic one that I could do.
The light bulb.
So you are the Messiah?
That's what I've been told.
I expected someone taller.
Or at least someone that doesn't look like a kitten.
So you're some sort of cat?
I'm a person.
Uh...
I'm letting the world die naturally.
Let's see.
Just got here, yeah.
We're gonna go to the tower.
We know that the tower contains a force that nobody can
comprehend.
The power is the strongest at the summit.
Maybe it will send you back home after you complete your
mission.
Maybe.
Oh.
Don't take my word for it, though.
We already know.
Screwdriver.
We got a screwdriver.
It's already been a couple days since I last played this, so
I'm kind of like...
What's inside the tower?
Trying to remember.
Nobody's ever entered it before.
At least nobody's ever.
History knows.
Who built it?
It's been here since the beginning of time.
Further assistance, we're good things.
Oh yeah, there was something in...
We go here and then Silver's like, Stop!
It's been a year since you played this game.
I haven't played this game since last year.
Go into the mines.
Thank you.
What's that?
Oh!
Oh.
Got that part of a camera?
That...
That was new.
That didn't flash before, right?
You were starting to black out.
I saw something.
That was a really short dream.
just now.
A dream.
Not a hallucination.
Oh, I saw something like...
Chippers, thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
A robot with a yellow eye.
That's strange.
Are you sure you're okay?
Yeah.
You know, now that you have mentioned it, there is a robot
who always insisted on going back to the abandoned mines.
Despite how long the mines have been in disrepair, I hope
he's okay.
He doesn't look broken or anything, but I didn't really see
him see him, you know.
Like I said, it was kind of like a dream.
And he was up close.
Yeah, I'm seeing things.
Sounds like some kind of visual glitch or hallucination.
That's what I said.
Whatever it is that living beings have.
Does that robot know you have a yellow eye?
I don't think I've seen any other robots like that.
I would not know.
Wait, they don't...
Oh, I thought Nico meant that Silver has a yellow eye.
I never met him myself.
Only heard of him from a friend of mine.
Your friend, huh?
Hold on, something in my pocket is...
Is that something in your pocket?
Are you just happy to see me?
What is happening?
This wasn't glowing before.
What is this?
That was going to be my question.
Where did you get that book?
They're both.
I am happy to see you.
Really?
I am just happy to see you.
I'm so happy to see you.
It was with me when I woke up back at the house.
I didn't really question it.
the time.
I flipped through a couple of pages, but I didn't understand
a... But I don't understand a word.
Is that just something Messiahs they're supposed to wake up
with?
No, I've never heard of anything like that.
I'm always happy to see you.
It's become a medical condition.
Like a virus?
But I know who wrote the book.
Oh?
However, I've only seen his books with a black clover on the
hover.
If you went through the trouble of putting yellow phosphor
in it, and the fact that you woke up with it in the first
place really has me intrigued.
A Minto virus.
Get infected, get infected, get infected.
Mad minky disease.
Yellow phosphor?
Well, yeah, that's the rare phosphor that people think the
sun is made of, right?
Wait a minute.
How do I know this?
Delicious!
I don't think anyone's told me about it.
Uh, I can show you if you'd like.
My friend gave me this a long time ago.
Looks like there's a clover in the necklace too!
Mint wouldn't leave us to be swallowed by darkness.
Nah.
Nico knows too much.
Silver's gonna push him down into the depths.
You know too much.
Like the book?
Well, it is the same person.
Oh, that's why I think this journal would be important.
You said it just started glowing?
Yeah.
That was right after your vision then.
This has to mean something.
Maybe you should at least try to read it again.
It's glowing now?
I feel like it's glowing.
I found this page.
New follower, looking forward to your stream.
Thank you!
Welcome!
Looks kind of like a drawing of this room.
Maybe it's telling us we should come here.
Which we did already.
So it looks like we're on our right track.
It's showing like...
Wait.
Like right...
Here, basically, no?
Yeah!
I did it!
I lined it up!
What just happened?
Dream Chasers!
Thank you for the gift!
Thank you!
I'm not sure.
I wasn't looking.
To be honest, neither was I.
I was just taking a closer look at the journal.
And then I found this page that looks like a drawing of this
room.
When I look back up, this minecart just showed up out of
thin air!
Should I be worried?
This looks like a standard issue minecart.
Oh my gosh, we're playing.
in Minecraft.
Which means it likely detected the motion in this room and
sent itself over.
Ah, that does make sense.
No, it was me.
It was all me.
It was me.
I deserve the credit.
Me.
I'm the inventor.
I'm just surprised it still works.
Guess that means we'll have a working vehicle now.
Wait, this is so new.
This is all new.
Not sure why you would want to visit the deeper mines, but
if you wanted to, soon, we now have that option.
Is the minecart even going to fit both of us?
No.
It was Adminto all along!
But I wanted you to come with us.
I know I've got Adminto, but honestly, this place gives me
the creeps.
Oh, I can still come with.
I would just have to follow along on the rails.
But doesn't it look a little precarious?
The magnetic rails can hold me in place.
It's only ever dangerous to walk on if you're an organic
being guys if i'm a ghost and like jelly and ectoplasm does
that count as organic i guess i don't have the metals in me
can't you just float i guess i could flow yeah i could flow
so
you guys don't want to see my legs so you guys are not leg
people okay i got it so if i got if i if i always floated
and never used my legs.
Wait, wait, wait.
That's what you said, though, no?
Legs only, stream when?
She's all legs.
Which I am.
Okay.
Silver just said that I am an organic being.
Gotcha.
There we go.
Oh, here we go.
Give me a big old push.
Oh, never mind.
It's actually quite slow.
Try to keep up, Silver.
Likes.
I do not recognize this place in the protocol.
This isn't what I'm supposed to be showing you at all.
How did you get here?
I can only think of one person.
He contacted you?
How long has he been doing this?
Minto always skips leg day.
No!
Call me to grant in the way I'm all about legs.
It doesn't matter at this point.
You are going out of bounds.
You should turn back.
Please turn back.
Bad things are going to happen.
Very bad things.
At this rate, Niko will be in danger.
Please turn back.
We have to go!
Niko is in danger anyway.
What danger could come from going into an abandoned mine?
Oh, the cart stopped.
Looks like this is as far as the tracks go.
where are we one of the old observation rooms looks like
it's still mostly intact oh what oh the terminal just
reactivated but the power was cut off so long ago weird oh
creepy maybe it runs on battery just like the steam the
steam VR set no that's not it whatever it is I need to
investigate okay will you be okay by yourself for a bit
don't worry i'm mean toes with me all right stay safe wait
can i investigate it too some sort of computer wait some
sort of small machine i wonder what it does i can feel my
hair standing up a little
oh we found him i recognize the light in your eyes You are
the person I am destined to meet.
Wait, it's New Game Plus and we're meeting new characters?
I too would feel safe with Adminto with me.
No kidding!
You would trust my judgment.
Ah, what if it's the Ghostbusters?
Now we're gonna get the heck out of here.
What is your name?
I'm Nico.
Do you know who sent you?
Oh.
Um, no?
Wait, do you mean who sent me to this world?
There was a robot a while back who told me about how I'm the
Messiah and stuff.
So I'm guessing I had Minto sent me.
With them being God and all.
The robot looks a little bit like you even.
Maybe you know each other?
Oh my gosh!
Nico, not all the robots know each other!
I cannot say.
Oh?
A lot of my memories have been removed for safety reasons.
Hey, can I get some of that?
Your memories were removed?
That's terrible.
Wait, I'm guessing that's less of a big deal for a robot.
I'm going to assume you do not know who sent you.
How did you get here then?
How did you reach this room?
here in a minecart but the minecart wasn't there when you
entered the mines was it oh yeah so how did you find it i
didn't really find it the robot lady thinks it's was just
the minecart coming to us but i remember looking at the
journal when it happened and when i looked up again the cart
was just there poof not poof it was more like a oh my gosh
guys i need to drink more coffee i'm I'm not tired, but I
can't stop yawning today.
Eepie.
Not Eepie.
Maybe a little Eepie.
I did nothing yesterday, though.
It was pretty nice.
I watched some Breaking Bad.
I did a little bit of work, but a tiny bit.
Just some time-sensitive things.
And I cleaned.
My New Year's Day was very relaxing.
The game's BGM may have a calming effect.
You know, it might actually be that.
And it's so like...
He's so nice to listen to.
I'm on season four.
The solstice has begun.
What's the solstice?
Oh, wait.
That was a password, wasn't it?
I'm on like see I'm on season four episode like two I think
maybe
solstice more than a season ahead of me I've been I've been
flying through it I'm not gonna lie um but I watch it and I
draw it's pretty nice and then what are there what six five
or Six?
Seasons?
Still thinking about doing a finale watch along?
The path in this game is called the Solstice Run.
Five seasons.
And then I watch Better Call Saul, which I'm so excited for
because I love Saul.
He's like, him, him and Mike are my favorites.
Gosh, it's scary.
But I like him too.
The El Camino movie.
What's that?
I don't know that one.
Also watch El Camino.
It's a movie with Jesse.
Oh, it's a sequel movie.
Breaking Bad Appelot!
Wait.
Was... Well, I guess...
as an epilogue.
I guess I know who lives.
I guess Jesse makes it out.
It's okay.
You guys.
I know you guys probably didn't even think about it at all.
Don't worry.
I would fumble like that too.
Don't even...
Maybe he dies in the movie.
So true.
It's, yeah, it's told from the perspective of his ghost.
It's okay.
I'm not even mad.
Don't worry, guys.
It's so funny, though.
It's actually Jesse Jr. His baby.
Who lived on
Good save, yeah good save He ate Walter's cancer Okay,
anyway Intouristic Please show me this journal Okay Then it
has already begun What?
What are the numbers?
What do they mean?
Can I take that out of his head?
Um...
Here.
Oh my god, I got his brain.
What is that?
I am entrusting you with my main memory disk.
You have passed the first test by showing me the book.
Now you will need to find a way to install the backup.
Install the...
Before you do that, though, someone else is here with you,
right?
Someone aside from Adminto, a resident of this world.
Yeah, the robot lady with the red hair.
She's in the computer room right now.
And please do not tell her you found me.
At least not yet.
She could just walk into the room.
She could literally walk in here right now.
Do you remember seeing numbers around?
These?
I don't know.
I can't be seen like this.
What?
You stinky?
Um, okay.
Please help me restore my memory.
Bring the disc back once you have the backup.
Okay.
Avoiding spoilers, so I'm here to say, hi, Mint.
Hello, thanks for the super chat, Leah.
Profit Bot Zero Backup System 1.0.
Please insert this.
That's a computer.
What is this?
Oh.
Is that Minto?
Minto robot.
And that's the hospital.
I remember that.
I don't know what the electricity one is though.
Residential tracking machine for reference and explanation
of the symbols.
Medical units are assigned to this building.
A robot is assigned to this building.
Okay, literally everybody.
They're shy.
It's shy guy.
Shy guy.
Just like me.
Electricity.
A power cell is assigned to this building.
this building.
Oh.
Interesting.
Tomatoes are first.
Ah, thank you.
How's it going?
This observation room isn't for the mines.
I've actually never been to this particular one.
Really?
You recognize it at first, though?
They all look the same.
Fair enough.
I did find something interesting, though.
All the databases seem to encode video feeds.
Right now, I can see various places in the barons the
outpost the residential areas even my own house they're all
shot from a top-down perspective too wait like like how I'm
looking at the game which means the cameras would have to be
in the air but I have never seen any cameras around the
drone wait no guys it's the birds oh my
Oh my god, Lizzie Bird, you have the same idea as me!
Getting kind of meta as if it didn't the first time, huh?
That's kind of spooky.
I might go investigate later, yeah.
Did you find anything interesting in the back room?
You were in there for a while.
Yeah, we found a dead end?
Happy Friday, man.
I've seen the base game, but never new game plus.
Curious to see what's different.
different thank you how about thank you happy friday it's
freaky friday it's freaky friday it's freaky friday it's
freaky friday with freaky minto with freaky minto a freaky
friday with freaky minto i see and leave
Freaky Friday, it's Freaky Friday.
I don't remember what to do.
I know we have to fix the battery.
How did I...
I replaced the glass on it.
I remember that.
Like, oh, I think we pulled the lens out here.
And then did I use that?
bottle to...
Oh wait.
We got the lens.
We have to find the thing to fix the...
It's Freaky Friday.
I'm in love.
I'm not sure you need to do that all this time.
But what about um turning on the power and and And...
And...
And stuff.
I don't need to turn the power on it yet.
Is this a mock desktop or is Mint using Edge 2026?
Okay, first of all, this is my...
This is my computer for game only.
So, it's not that I use it.
Oh, here we go.
And here's the screwdriver here.
No, I can't.
We lost the screwdriver.
There was a...
There was a... There was a pole.
There was some sort of stick.
It's not this one.
Where was it?
I don't know if I have to do all of this anymore, but...
They have games on your computer.
I got games on my computer.
We need to open that so that we can get the battery even
though I'm not sure if I need it or not.
I don't know.
He says just make backups but what does he mean by that?
Stop being so vague I need the hand holding right now!
I need to be handheld.
Wait was there anything in here?
Make babies.
I have for some reason I don't think that's what he meant.
Are you projecting?
Ah!
I found the pipe.
Yippee!
Uh, no.
No walking.
No napping right now, Nico.
Only walking and working.
I'm putting you to...
Oh no.
There's some weird square stuff.
Oh!
Wait, what's wrong with...
Minto!
Minto's abstracting.
Minto bot.
So sad.
Is this the amazing digital circus?
Yeah.
It is now.
Oh wait, uh, oh, sorry.
there we go.
I'm not gonna smash the bottle.
There we go.
Okay.
Oh, the flatten it.
That's right.
I forgot about that.
I'm kind of been like, I really like amazing digital circus
because I feel like there's enough.
It's quirky enough.
What?
Oh, whoops.
I went too far.
It's quirky enough, but I don't feel like it's like usually
trying too hard.
And it's like, it seems just it seems like I can't get into
shows like has been hotel and things like that because I
always feel like like I don't find I don't like stuff where
it's just like ha ha cursing is the punchline that's not
like it's just or like sex joke is the punchline those kinds
of things make it it's just not my my type of humor I'm
really enjoying the way they're handling the story
progression right like I feel like the amazing digital
circus is like you know if you haven't checked it out yet
because you're worried about it being like a husband hotel I
think it's actually not like it at all so um I really
suggest it I really recommend it um and it's it's really
really good I think the animation is so cute I think like
such a cute character design i love her and and one thing
that i also really like about it is one of my idol oh she's
is she's really into it so she really loves jacks and so i
get to go whenever i get to see her in japan i'll get to
talk to her about it i'd be like jacks are so cute and she'd
be like yeah i recommend it i really like it
You like them both?
Different moods?
That's totally fair.
I'm not trying to like...
I'm not trying to yuck your yum.
I'm just saying that it's not my cup of tea.
Which is totally... Okay.
You like jacks?
My favorite character for Amazing Digital Circus is...
Kinger my goal?
I love Kinger.
I like him all, honestly.
So many people liking Kinger.
Wow.
Disappearing guy is so funny.
Guys, I think some people are trying to guess who I'm
talking about as my Oshi.
You guys are not going to know her.
She's a very indie, indie idol in Japan.
I don't think you know her.
Oshi does not always mean VTuber.
It's already fully charged.
Yeah!
Was it here?
Yes.
Big machine.
Oh, oh, I forgot to charge the battery.
It's Ado.
So true.
Yippee!
That's how you charge rechargeable batteries.
So fast, so easy.
All you need is a light bulb and two seconds and it'll
charge.
Whoa!
Alright, it's alive!
Everybody's alive!
The reason I really wanted to do this was because I wanted
to check the computer.
The screen says documents.
I can't seem to make the computer do anything else.
Do I have to go to my own documents for real?
Wait.
One second?
Then I go to my own documents for real?
Documents?
Oh wait, that's the wrong thing.
Oh wait, there was this.
Hold on.
That we got last time.
That was like, it said solstice here.
But it's called password.
The code you need is 249241.
Is that what I need?
For the gas mask?
It was right there the whole time!
Did it know?
Does it know?
Does she know?
Does he know?
Do they know?
Is it here?
I don't think so.
Oh, here it is.
Oh, oops, that was too biased.
Okay.
Two, what was it, four, nine, two,
two, four, nine, two, four, one, two, four, one.
Oh my God!
It worked!
Let's go.
Easy game.
Hey!
All right, moving over here.
I have to, like, work with two different mice, so it's kind
of freaky.
Um, I have my ways.
I see.
What's in the safe?
It's a gas mask!
Oh, it's empty.
Oh.
Run away!
What is that?
Very good, very good.
do for New Year's.
You know what one day I want to do you guys?
One day I want to be one of the confetti people for Times
Square.
You got drunk!
Slept.
That's always a good thing.
Catch up on your sleep.
Watch the VTubers.
Yeah!
Had lunch with family.
Worked.
I was at work.
No.
Big family gathering.
Mahjong bingo vtubers.
Wait, the whole...
You put vtubers on the big screen?
Couldn't see fireworks because of thick fog.
No!
You know, I didn't see fireworks either, except in the VR
child.
Still coming back from Wisdom Teeth, removable Murphy.
So I did play a bunch of video games.
Video games.
Uh...
Alright, now we can run around with our mask on.
So I'm trying to not play the game as I did prior.
But I'm also trying to figure out what we do.
You might like the Ram Shackle Pilot and Laksa Daisy if you
haven't seen them for animated shows that are coming up.
Laksa Daisy?
That's the one with the cats in the club, right?
The freaky cats in the club.
Not a lot of fireworks this year because I ran.
No!
Okay, we gotta go find some numbers, everybody.
Let's go find...
Let's go to the dorms and see if there's numbers.
The gangster cats.
I don't know, Ram Shackle, though.
I'll check that one out.
Thank you, Strider!
Thank you!
Thank you so much for the super chat, too.
I really appreciate it.
Do we see the numbers?
one do i have to count these maybe
eight eight of them but i'm scared of ladders you don't have
to count no i have one of one oh wait on on i got shadow
band on youtube unable to send chat messages or super chats
hours of fun hooray PSA for folk support and help with that.
Why did you get a shadow band?
Oh, I don't know.
You'll see a number.
Okay, okay.
Thank you.
What do you have to say?
All of these terminals do not boot.
I'm not sure what to do now.
Oh my gosh, being a robot with no purpose.
So sad.
Okay, we'll see a number.
We'll see a number.
I don't see one.
The music is so nice.
The building has numbers.
Oh, outside!
Wait, this is 1-1-8.
Oh, I see!
Hello, hi!
I am stationed here by yourself?
Okay, so 1-1-8 has a stationed robot.
Okay, hold on, I need a notepad for this.
Open up a third notepad because I have two open already.
1-1-8 equals stationed robot.
Okay.
Let's go check out...
Well, I guess the other ones don't have the numbers in on
the outside because there was nothing in there.
Wait?
I'm kidding.
I'm a liar.
119 has nothing, though.
Wait, no.
I'm a liar again.
You guys, I can't stop lying.
It's like it's my New Year's resolution or something.
This one...
119 has the battery in it.
Battery.
My resolution...
is to gaslight more.
The battery.
Okay.
What was the other one?
Yeah.
This one is 1-1-3.
And it has...
1-1-3 empty?
Did it have something?
I promise that I'd lie more this year.
Okay.
That's exactly me too!
It has nothing.
Got a moribble MM.
Flip it around.
Wicked Witch!
This one is...
1-1-2.
Hop it all.
1-1-7.
1-1-7's also empty.
Do the notes give a hint?
Oh my god, I keep pressing too many times.
Looks like we're supposed to pack stuff for evacuation.
I wish these books weren't so heavy.
They're by the author.
Author, I can't throw them away.
Oh, this is the mom.
Love mom.
Alright, so we need...
Four?
Five, six.
Here?
Zero!
Okay, we need one.
One.
One, four, five, six.
No numbers after that.
A robot.
It's beyond repair.
That has to be a stationed robot, right?
I think so.
Stationed robot.
I already got seven Don't you dare Don't you dare
Um Is this all of them?
Look out point?
What is that?
Oh, okay.
This is good.
This is fine.
Wait, wait.
We'll get her next time.
What's happening?
Excuse me, excuse me, excuse me, how many works to do.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
So there's a robot.
empty 12 hopito 18 robot 13 empty 19 battery oh map
reconfiguration successful
oh i put it in repairing backup writing to disk 26 complete
34 complete this is all i needed to do 40% complete.
100% complete.
Ejecting disk.
The numbers, Minky, what do they mean?
I know what they mean now.
Please help me restore my memory.
Bring the disk, the bisque.
Bring me a tomato bisque once you have the backup.
I'm very hungry.
Does this work?
inserting disk, rebooting.
Ah.
Are you okay?
Sure.
So I guess it worked?
Yes.
I believe a proper introduction is in order.
I am the prototype.
Originally named Prophetbot.
Don't forget the grilled cheese.
Oh yeah.
Some garlic grilled cheese with a tomato bisque.
Oh, yeah.
Otherworldly tech doesn't hang out at 100% forever?
Amazing!
Sonobisk doll mention?
Delicious.
Guys, I realized, I talked about this the other day.
With my last meal of 2026.
No, 2025.
Being pizza rolls?
And then I realized, because I ate right before the collab
but it was already 2026 for me my first meal of 2026 was
pizza rolls
non-stop pizza rolls what kind of pizza rolls okay here's my
recipe you get the crescent rolls Like they could be like a
Pillsbury or whatever brand, off-brand pizza roll is from
your local grocery.
Just as long as there are crescent rolls, they're like in a,
they're in like a roll, a tube.
The ones are the ones, the ones are the kinds of tubes that
pop and scare you and I don't like them.
But you, you get those and you roll them out and they're in
like little triangles and you peel them apart from the
triangles.
And then there's a big old fat side of the triangle.
And that one you smack on a couple pepperoni.
Like a one pepperoni, two pepperoni, three pepperoni.
I do four pepperoni.
And then you get a mozzarella stick, a cheese stick.
And then you bend that sucker in half.
You tear it into half.
And then you put it on top of the pepperoni.
And then you roll it all together.
And then you fold in the sides.
And then you get some pizza sauce And you, after you finish
baking them You dip it in the pizza sauce And it's very good
It's quite delicious It's pretty good And you can make a lot
of them Because you get a lot of peploni And you'll get the
mozzarella sticks also comes with a lot Yeah It's yum!
It's yum!
I was literally writing to call this out the pop when you
did the same bass.
Also, hi, Brad!
Welcome back!
Thank you!
Peploni, peploni.
I had olive garden today.
You got them endless bread roll, bread, bread, endless
bread, bread.
What is... what is a bread...
More olive bread.
What is, how much a bread is...
What kind of bread is it out of the olive garden?
Is it bread sticks?
Binto gaming.
I'm gaming!
I was built to greet the savior of the old world.
Wait.
A prophet robot.
Like the one I met?
Hey, I was right about you guys looking alike.
Well, the prophet bot out there is now a gross
simplification of my design.
Someone's bitter.
Just bread.
breadsticks oh my gosh one place that we went to in animal
kingdom um it's funny because ashton kept choosing these
places to eat and they were all like pretty but the first
place we ate at was a restaurant in animal kingdom and at
first she looked at the at the menu and it seemed pretty
good and they had like a bread bread basket and we were like
heck yeah we love a bread basket and guys for the first time
ever there was a I've never heard of this spicy bread why
was the bread spicy shouldn't that be like the non-spicy
part of the meal because it's the thing that will that will
calm your mouth when it's not when it's spicy it was so
strange all of the bread was really bad there was one cheesy
bread that we were like oh yeah this is gonna be so great it
was it was the best out of all of them but it was like more
of like a mochi texture and then The cheese was not so
cheese.
It was strange.
I had jalapeno bread from the grocery store.
It was not that, though.
I think it was like a...
Like a...
A flakes of pepper or something, you know.
What's next?
Spicy milk?
I know.
It was really strange.
Yeah.
Apparently food at Disney is extremely hit or miss.
We still ate, though.
It was fine.
Anyway, back to the game.
That is to say, he is much more primitive by comparison.
Embarrassingly, so...
Hey, he seemed all right to me.
You don't understand.
Not only is he not tamed, he was tailor-made for this much
smaller, simpler world to begin with.
I was not.
I was built before the real world.
ended the real world wait what's happening oh right you
don't know nico do you remember the ending dusty dog thank
you so much for the time gifted and optimistic optimistic
welcome to membership thank you wait is this like the ending
i just did excuse me the fact that you found me at all means
this is not your first time in this world wait but the world
shouldn't have ended We saved the world!
Continuous pizza rolls.
The game was rigged right from the start.
You have already been summoned to this world once before.
In fact, you've already traversed the entire world and went
through the tower already.
And in the ending, you either put in the sun or didn't.
What matters is that you are here now.
Armento has succeeded.
successfully bypassed the one-shot restriction and brought
you back again.
We eat fried bread with mayo and cheese.
Best thing ever.
Fried bread sounds crazy.
That sounds so yummy.
That sounds pretty good.
Lithuania.
I've never tried Lithuania food.
I...
Oh.
Thought something was weird.
When I woke up in the house, I called out a name.
It turned out to be Adminto's name.
And then I back at the other robot.
I even asked Adminto if we met before.
Felt like such a dumb question at the time.
It looks like you are at least aware of it.
Anything fried is delicious.
Soutre.
To some extent.
It's just this weird feeling, okay?
I don't...
Actually, I remember going through the world.
I just remember I had Minto.
It's really starting to freak me out.
Calm down.
Look, just like how my memories were locked away, yours are
too.
Thank you for the summertime!
But you're a living being.
You don't even need extra hardware to remember.
Just close your eyes.
focus say that at a country fair not everything should be
fried oh my gosh i've seen like country fair menus and stuff
they have like fried oreo i don't know it sounds good though
no fried oreo
fried butter fried fried butter fried okra i've never tried
okra before everything is fried
Fried pickles?
Wait, wait.
Actually, I like those.
Wait, those are actually a real thing.
I like fried pickles.
Fried Twinkies.
I've never had a Twinkie before.
Fried soda.
Fried ice cream.
I've heard of that before too, though.
It's kind of good.
It's got like a crunchy outside.
It's kind of yummy.
Hmm.
Fried mineral water That's like That's Oh wait, fried milk
tea Oh Indian pan fried okra Bindi masala Oh What does an
okra taste like?
I've always never tried it because it scares me Because the
outside looks like it's so hard Like it looks like it's like
a shell That it shouldn't be eaten Oh I don't think you'd
like fried okra.
It's kind of slimy like natto and texture.
Oh, it's slimy?
Too slimy for me?
Slimy in a good way.
I don't know guys, I'm not good with the slimy texture.
Hmm.
It's not that different from tomato.
Oh really?
I can eat tomato.
Slimy and better.
Oh.
When it's fried it's not that slimy I would hope not.
Okay, back to the game.
Just close your eyes and focus.
Focus on what?
Try to picture a big room made entirely of glass.
Glass.
Nico, what's this made of?
No matter what you saw in the tower, the top room never
changes.
All right.
Nico, what's the tower made of?
Oh!
The elevator!
Oh, yes!
I was all there before.
No way!
I was there, wasn't I?
At the tower!
I've been... I've played these games before!
I love Apollo!
Yeah!
I love quoting Apollo.
I've been through the tower.
There we go.
all that much but the room with the sun it feels like such a
long time ago yeah it was like a couple days ago it doesn't
make sense it was last year Nico I don't know Apollo my top
recommended YouTube channel Apollo Apollo the bird if I
already finished the mission why didn't anything change and
why doesn't anyone know me the other prophet bought the
robot lady.
None of them remember who I am.
Of course not.
The residents do not have that capacity.
NPC memories do not last beyond the scope of a session.
NPC?
Bro, you can't just call people
NPCs.
I feel like being called an NPC, especially by like a
zoomer, is so, it feels so offensive.
I feel a really easy way to rage bait me.
It's like soul, it's...
It's so...
It makes me so angry.
SMH, we're all Minto's NPCs.
Getting mad at Zoomers, typical NPC behavior.
mpc is literally calling you not a real person it's messed
up i know i feel like they're erasing my humanity i'm not i
was a former human but i was human it just is bought a
ticket and flight to see you live ramiya thank you does that
happen to you often be called an mpc no i've never been
called an mpc before but but i've seen people being called
mpcs and i'm like This is so...
It feels too mean.
It feels so mean.
You can call me chopped.
You can call me ugly.
I don't care.
But like...
Every NPC is the pro tag of their own game.
...
Technically, we're all NPCs to each other.
You make your own choices.
Every time I think of it, I think of it as like an oblivion
NPC.
And just someone.
Like they think that I'm like someone that goes cop cop cop
cop cop.
They're running around.
No!
Stop.
You violated the law.
But I do that IRL.
Maybe we should.
Maybe I have an NPC.
I'm the NPC of the Matrix.
Everyone else is Neo and I'm the only NPC.
But also, okay, spin it like this, you guys.
You're a non-playable character, right?
Which means no one can ever be you.
If you're an NPC, that means no one can ever be you.
You're your own character.
They came with mods!
No!
So you just spend time thinking about being called an NPC?
Yeah, I'm like creating enemies in my brain.
Winto is a nearly perfect cute ghost made idol.
Nearly!
Nobody's perfect.
I gotta work it.
I feel better about...
about NPC-ness now.
Yeah.
It's all about being positive.
You know, the characters.
The world's residents.
NPCs can never recreate Minto's raw energy.
Like that?
What kind of energy?
Yeah!
Minto is an NPC naturally pretty cute.
I'm gonna need you all to stop it right now.
What is this?
A compliment Minto hour?
No!
It's time to stop.
We're playing a very serious video game.
And it's time to stop it.
It's time to quit.
It's time to quit it.
DJ, quit that thing.
Had died.
I heard tickets.
What's happening?
I don't get on Twitter.
Ah, Ward!
Tickets for my 3D Jazz show.
But unfortunately, the tickets that were for the pre-sale.
I posted about it.
It's not just on Twitter.
On YouTube, I posted about it too.
Cute ghost on my computer screen.
You better clean it.
You better run a virus scan.
Okay, back to game.
All their past memories are built into their code, but...
The characters themselves don't really exist until Adminto
wills it.
Me?
Oh yeah, because I opened the game.
You're right.
Not that.
Now's not the hour.
All hours are for complimenting Minto.
Stop!
Same story for the world itself.
Doesn't really exist unless Adminto initiates the program.
Oh.
The program?
Oh my gosh, one-shot program.
Zoom in so we can see those cute hearts in your eyes.
Stop looking at me Stop looking at me The world machine Oh A
universe simulator that runs on Admintho's computer Whoa
this is getting crazy Okay the game was already meta before
But it's getting crazy meta We are all in it right now So
we're not real Oh you are Which is why you're so important.
The biggest flaw of the program is that it cannot be run
independently.
It requires the mental processing abilities of a real person
from another universe.
Oh, I wonder how my cookie clicker is doing.
You got one of those universe machines?
Welcome to Solstice.
Think of it like one of your dreams.
When you wake up, it's gone.
this world has a physical location inside a computer which
ad minto operates
for this year year over this world to continue existing
around you ad minto has to be in constant contact with you
if ad minto ends the program the world will go into a stasis
oh my god don't say constant contact sorry my ol trauma
sorry oh my god oh sorry oh god i almost threw up on don't
welcome to membership thank you welcome back sorry it was a
program i had to use
does ad minto know this of course from ad minto's
perspective the world machine isn't all that special it's no
different from other recreational game type software they
may have installed on their computer.
Hola, Minto!
Hola, V.
They can also regenerate the world as many times as they'd
like now that the restriction is nullified.
Yeah, I have Harvester and Mystery of the Druids.
All of that is consistent with their concept of what a
computer game looks like.
Am I just a game to you?
The Slack notification sound is your PTSD game.
trigger.
It's like a...
How do you do the slack?
It'll ask you to jump programs to a different game.
Oh my god.
Why am I even here?
What am I supposed to do to save if...
Save if everything is just...
Wait, wait, what am I even supposed to save if everything is
just...
Fake!
Oh, Nico's crying, guys!
Fake is a harsh word, but...
And why did Adminto never tell me anything about any of
this?
I cannot speak for Adminto.
I just want to go home.
But every time Adminto runs the program, I come back?
Correct.
Is this why I feel like...
Is this why it feels like I haven't been home for so long?
Maybe.
It's my fault now.
Once you've established a mental link with the world, you
cannot break it unless the world is...
saved.
But at this point, the world can never be truly saved.
That's...
Wait, what do you mean?
What do you mean by that?
Why would... What am I doing all this for then?
Why would you create a world like...
Like this?
Wait, what?
Why would you make a world that's duped from the beginning?
Why would you keep bringing me back to it?
Adminto!
Aren't you supposed to be some kind of God?
Oh, wait.
Aren't you supposed to be a kind God?
Wait, I'm some kind of god.
Oh, communication error.
Kind god.
Kind of god.
Oh, it appears that we have some confusion here.
Minto's a meanie.
Yeah, I'm a meanie.
And Minto did not build the world, Nico.
It was playing the developers.
It's not Adminto's fault.
It's the people called the devs.
Adminto only owns a machine that is able to generate the
world from pre-existing code.
Adminto!
No!
They actually have fairly limited control of the events.
The world was built by someone else altogether.
Someone you cannot begin to follow.
The devs.
designed to be futile quests that it is now but too many
things went wrong there's a type of signal disruption that
he never expected it's eating away at the world slowly
rendering it into an unrecognizable mess even if you bring
back the sun it will not go away a virus the square stuff
isn't it i remember those from before then you know what to
watch out for The creator knows what might be causing it,
but there is nothing that he could do.
What was that one game?
I think it was what called There Is No Game.
And, like, at the end sequence, there's a video of, like,
the dev actually, like, working on the game or something.
Because that was going to happen, and this we're going to
have, like, we're going to have a Skype call with the dev.
I got my ticket.
Hello, my operator.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Welcome back.
We're 20 bucks.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, yeah, it was like that, right?
That was pretty funny.
I liked it.
Until now.
You managed to find me, after all.
You being here was due to his help.
Oh, I guess it has something to do with the journal.
Correct.
Looks like he wants to have one final attempt at fixing it.
And he might need to do it through you.
Oh, cool.
how to get to the Glen.
Whatever you did in your last session, you should stick with
it for now.
But the...
But the Minto bot was... was blocked over.
I remember a boat.
More specifically, fixing a robot that drives the boat.
There's a game I could recommend if you like these kind of
metagames.
Doki Doki Literature Club.
Alright, then go do that.
But...
The boat robot has those squares over it.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, then do whatever you must to find a new boat.
There are plenty of machine parts around the barrens that
can be repurposed.
You seem enthusiastic.
That was sarcasm.
Knowing everything isn't real, really does make it feel
pointless.
But you do want to go home, right?
Yeah, but how will I know that this isn't just another...
session might be the last one.
Actually, it is the last one because I'm finishing the game
today.
The creator is mobilizing things, throwing everything into
this one last shot.
Oh my gosh, it's not one shot anymore.
It's one last shot.
Wait, that's kind of awesome.
There might not be enough internal resources left for
Adminto to be able to generate another session after this.
Just go find a new boat for now.
But please be careful.
What about you?
I will meet you at the docks later.
Need to take care of something first.
Oh!
Uh-oh.
Hey, you okay in there?
I did what I could with the terminals for now, and...
It's you.
Admin, though, can't afford more RAM for more sessions.
It's too real.
Stop.
That would have been a cool, a good sequel name.
yeah you're the robot that insisted on living in the mines
are you not my friend told me to keep an eye out for you
should we ever cross paths is it clean up his internet
history first likewise your friend gave you something the
last time you saw each other can you show me what it is wait
you know about the amber I just asked to see it didn't I
okay Smarty pants.
Alright, here it is.
Not so.
He seemed to trust you, so I will treat you as an ally as
well.
Please listen carefully.
Oh, because they both have the Clover symbol, I probably.
Listen carefully.
You need to escort the Messiah for the remainder of the
barons.
I predict a high concentration of square particle
disruptions in the near future.
No way.
Oh my gosh, wait, what's going to happen to you?
thought this prophet bought yes way it's likely that
structures in the vicinity of the Messiah might be affected
making it far more treacherous pilgrimage than the previous
oh or expectations Aminto and the Messiah need all the extra
help they can get rid of understood wait why can't they join
us for the whole journey though okay Guess we should head
back soon.
Even without the squares, the mines are not a safe place to
be.
Come on, I'll wait for you outside.
Wait, you literally have to escort me.
Don't go ahead of me.
I want to ask you.
Rude?
She left.
If you were going to ask her about being not real, save your
breath.
None of the people here know their predicament.
In fact, I don't think they can even comprehend it.
interest to just pretend like we never had this
conversation.
Causing mass confusion in this world's residence would
likely result in unfavorable conditions for you.
Predicament.
She is real to me.
Yeah, stop saying that about my waifu.
Koharu knows I exist.
She's real.
She calls me Sensei every day.
All right.
Wait, what about you?
How did you know?
We never had this conversation, remember?
Wait, can I ask?
Can I talk to him one more time?
Trying to establish connection here.
Sorry.
True!
Come on, let's go back.
I remember it.
What happened in the tower?
What is spooky music for?
What I tried to do and how you managed to see through it
all.
Oh, yeah, yeah, I definitely did that.
We have been through all of this.
Even though it was only supposed to run once, you still
managed to come back.
How did you come back?
How did you bring Nico back?
And then you even managed to break out of bonds.
Oh, not bonds, sorry, bounds.
Sorry.
Bringing Nico to places that should have, that never should
have been.
James Bond's.
I'm Bond's.
It was him, wasn't it?
And now, now, Nico is upset.
What even happened in that room back there?
What did Nico learn?
Nico is upset.
I can feel it.
I told you to turn back, Adminto.
But you've chosen to trust that man instead of me.
No, not even that.
Just his book.
His ghost!
This world is not real.
You joke.
You joked the...
You...
Wait, you broke the James box.
I can't even...
I can't even read a comment.
You just...
Sorry, a serious moment.
Serious moment.
The people are not real.
Nico is upset.
Nico is...
No, no, no, no, no.
Everything is...
Wrong!
Silver walked over, like nothing was wrong.
The slowest, so unconcerned.
The minecart.
Earthquake?
The tunnel back out just collapsed.
No.
What are we gonna do?
I... wait.
The exit just caved, didn't it?
I already know.
I saw this coming, but this is a bit more sudden than I
anticipated.
Both of you follow me where to the way out
Mysterious Hello all of us are here a way out There is an
emergency exit behind my computer terminal We did not want
anyone to stumble upon this route so the terminal has been
weighed down
It cannot be moved by normal means But with our combined
effort, it might budge Maybe I am not strong I'm not that
strong either If that doesn't work, we might need to dig
around it And you could have just asked
So sexy
That's a very different game What a way out That's with the
guys That's the guys Sorry, that's the guy's in jail, right?
Come on.
Show off.
Oh my gosh.
She just got, she just fixed it for you.
I would appreciate it if you do not linger here.
Okay.
I linger.
I'm just a fool.
I don't know.
Come in through to you You know I'm just a fool for you You
got me rubbed around your finger Do you have to let it
linger?
Do you have to?
Do you have to let it linger?
I don't even know where this tunnel leads.
This is a way out?
No, this is one shot.
There wasn't any data on this path in the server room.
It's new.
Miko, get in the Minecraft cart.
Sorry.
Okay.
Get in the Minecraft.
Alright, guys.
Keep up.
Uh-oh.
My droid.
I really did.
But I...
De-stabilizing.
I'm sorry, Miko.
I tried to protect you But can't hold off forever
What was that?
Here too?
Watch out!
Ah!
Silver!
Are you okay?
I'm fine, I'm fine.
I can still hold it up, but you two need to.
Ew, robot!
What are you waiting for?
Take the child and get out!
Oh, she's sacrificing herself.
Literally walking away.
No urgency whatsoever.
Ah!
No!
What do we do?
You have to take this.
What?
The memory disc end?
This is where we part ways.
Just walk around it.
He just walks away.
Yeah, taking a stroll.
You go the path ahead.
We'll lead you to the Glen.
Right by the city gate.
When you're in the city, go find someone named Cedric.
Give him the disc.
Well, what happens if I...
What if the squares?
Hurry!
Just chugging along.
Lally, dally, dally.
Don't forget the mission.
Adminto, I don't understand the world.
The prophet bought what he was saying.
Is the world really just...
Just...
Is it?
I don't...
I mean, who am I to say that it's fake?
I don't know.
Be honest.
It's real if it means something to you.
That's how I feel, right?
I mean, it's real in that I'm playing this right now.
If it didn't exist, I wouldn't be playing the game.
Yes, but no?
Yeah, it's complicated.
It's not one set answer, I feel.
Right.
You're real to us, me.
Wait, it's not about me.
Constructed doesn't mean fake.
Yeah, right.
I think that's not lying if I say no.
You're just saying that.
Normally, I wouldn't believe it, but it just adds up.
Everything adds up.
I don't know what I'm supposed to do.
If I can't fix the world, I can't go back home.
But the world is already so messed up.
don't get fixed what will happen to the world where would i
even go
nico so sad sad nico with the ripe old
sad sad sad in the lord sad sad oh my god sad
Oh, poor baby!
Oops, sorry.
I think, therefore I am.
Yeah, exactly.
We're looking for Cedric.
I think I remember something.
I remember what I did at the end.
I remember putting in the sun.
And then everything got really bright.
I don't remember a lot of the details.
But none of it matters now, does it?
I just got brought back anyway.
Oh, we're back here!
Part of the ground is missing.
I wonder if it's safe to walk across these vines.
One way to find out, I guess.
Oh!
They're safe.
Cool, we learned.
Wait, what's on the other side, though?
Why are you doing this?
I don't want to!
I don't mean to.
Maybe I'm a little evil.
Square.
That's the city gate, yeah!
It's...
Uh-oh.
Oh my god, there's so many...
Oh, can I not walk on this?
Are you okay?
Please do not approach.
The gate is closed until further notice.
No!
It's so sad!
Now we're navigating the world with all this going on.
The bridge is broken.
Oh, over here?
No?
Was there anything I could cross?
Am I blind?
There was another door.
There was?
This one?
Because this is the bed.
Earlier.
Oh, there was.
I missed it.
Not this one, right?
No.
Oh, this one!
Hello!
A deeper ruins are ahead.
Do note that they are partially flooded.
Oh, yeah.
This is where those kids live.
Square.
More of those squares.
This is what they meant with Be There or Be Square.
Being square.
Actually, the only time people have wanted to be square is
for the Minecraft movie.
Why didn't they allow them to be square?
Why did we actually have like real life Jack Black?
What about SpongeBob?
That guy's all square.
Square pants.
What is this way?
Oh, this is...
I wonder if she's here.
It's hip to be square.
Savior.
You're here to see me?
What happened to you?
Hold on.
I need to concentrate.
The islands will collapse if I don't do something.
That's why the vines...
Oh my gosh!
Wait, the islands are collapsing!
The same reason why we had live-action Scooby-Doo movies
apparently.
But Scooby-Doo was never square.
Minecraft has always been square block.
grow is that why there are vines everywhere are you trying
to hold the land together my powers the best I could do yes
that's should I leave the Sun here for you I know you wanted
to see it tempting but I mustn't the Sun brings me comfort
but stress is good for this fear is good makes me strong
vines grow If I'm at ease, the vines might retreat.
They're all in danger, Savior.
The villagers, the children.
My final hours.
Mustn't go to waste.
David Hasselhoff was real in the Spudgebob movie.
Yeah.
You're not wrong there.
Like I was in a movie.
The people deserve to live even if just for another day.
Oh!
Do not worry.
I am fine.
Everything is bad in this.
Oh my gosh.
Kick it!
The pathway is blocked.
By blocks!
Wait a minute.
I remember something about this.
Yeah!
Never knew it'd be so easy.
Look at that little smile.
ow my foot ow
oh the door I knew we'd lose our home eventually but I
wasn't expecting it to happen so soon oh geez hold on my
second eyes I'm gonna do a throat mint real quick because my
throat's been like so flimmy
oh my stars you're the savior um uh it's an honor to meet
you yes i'd invite you inside but as you can see our home is
it's got squares in it cannibalism yeah i can do it again i
do it again
yes alula thank you it's getting everywhere now isn't it the
squares they're way more than before even the gates of the
refuge is destroyed now That didn't happen last time.
Last time?
Awkward.
Nothing!
Almost let that slip on me too.
Guess I should introduce myself again.
My name is Nico.
Nico.
Oh gosh, would it not be rude to call you by name?
No worries.
Calamus?
How did you know my name?
I didn't even remember his name.
Oh my gosh.
Nico's spoiling everything.
Not again.
The Messiah just knows these things, Kalamas.
Right?
Yes, of course.
Phew.
Don't tell Nico anything ever.
That is supposed to be a secret.
Don't tell...
Don't tell Nico anything ever.
You were saying about the gate?
Oh, right.
Looks like I can't get in the city through the old gate
anymore.
Do either of you know another way to get in?
I remember.
I mean, I heard that there's some sort of hidden passage
around here somewhere.
Oh, a passage to the burial grounds.
That's the one.
But I'm not sure if that'll be of any use here.
It's been flooded for a long time and there's no boat.
Oh, my gosh.
We're probably going to...
We're probably gonna wheel the boat with the book again.
Cannibalism came up at the Christmas party.
I was out on Sunday.
Made me think of you.
What do you mean?
Why are...
I mean...
I don't...
Entirely mind that you think of me.
But...
That's your brand now, Minto.
What's another cannibalism game I can play?
Red Dead Redemption?
Yeah, what kind of party were you at?
Christmas party?
With cannibalism?
Kind of awesome.
There's cannibalism and Red Dead Redemption?
There is, uh...
There's like a few like creepy homes and stuff you can go
to.
Oh, the forest!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
The forest.
The Donner Party?
Is there a Donner Party game?
There has to be.
Not to mention the burial grounds itself is pretty far from
the city.
The forest.
That game is, I guess it is cannibalism.
but they got like freaky leggy monsters and stuff
the night folk in Red Dead 2 scare me I've seen so many like
clips of Red Dead Redemption I don't know anything about the
story I know one thing that might be a spoiler but
I know so much about about like some of the The more
creepier things in it.
It's long.
Yeah, that's the one thing that stops me from playing it.
Convo had something to do with little kids crying about
non-kids sections at books or being adult books.
Somehow that led to cannibalism.
Is it because cannibalism is not for children, maybe?
Human monsters in the forest That's so true I've played the
forest And you do eat people I've eaten people in the forest
Gosh maybe I really have A lot of cannibalism in my history
Silly the game or irl forest yeah i'm back in my backyard of
the forest i'm in my forest backyard and i'm i'm just
cannibalizing everything
no you want to know what i saw in my backyard yesterday a
pysum yeah I saw Paisa!
It was so cute!
That's not cannibalism.
I also wouldn't eat that guy.
Bigfoot, I wish.
Would you guys believe me if I was like, my home is the home
of Bigfoot?
They eat ticks and bad stuff.
Possums are the best.
For sure.
Boo, here she comes.
Watch out, I boo, she'll chew you up.
Oh, wait.
Wait, oh, what's that song?
Watch out, I boo, she'll chew you up.
She's a man eater.
Okay, back to game.
I would still like to see it.
we have all right in that case please follow us the good
thing that's not blocked by the blocks minecraft taking over
the game is like play minecraft right now play minecraft
right now at least the courtyard is unaffected for now we
usually get to the burial grounds through our friend but he
hasn't been here in forever normally this courtyard would be
where we meet up i hope he comes back soon Is this it?
Yeah.
One second, though?
Ball.
It's a ball.
That's mine.
It doesn't bounce as much as it used to, though.
Eat to let Minto eat you.
Possum.
I think I see it.
Wait, why does it have a beak?
Why does it got a beak?
Maybe.
Is that him?
Oh my god, I saw him.
Tiko!
Niko, what's wrong?
You looked like you were about to faint.
It's not the first time that's happened.
Oh my god.
Walter White.
Earlier I was in the barons and I saw something like this
too.
It was like a dream, but only for a split second.
Sounds like a vision.
Like something a prophet would see.
I guess.
Oh my god, that looks like a possum.
Yes, that looks so good.
The robot lady I was with earlier had a fancy word for it
though.
Hallucination?
Wait.
Let me check something.
Time to whip out my book, baby.
It's glowing.
Oh, I was right.
Huh?
When I had the vision back at the Barrens, the book started
glowing too.
I wanted to see if I could get it to happen again, and...
Where did you get that?
Oh, I had it with me when I woke up in this world.
It looks like one of our friends' books.
Except it's glowing.
That's what the lady said, too.
Nice book.
Thank you.
Armino, let's see if we can do anything with the journal in
this room.
Maybe here?
On the clover?
Wait a second.
Is the clover the hint?
Of where to stand?
I'm our genius!
Whoa!
How did that boat get there?
Okay, I'm pretty sure it has to do with this journal now.
The exact same thing happened back at the barons.
I don't think I noticed the clover in the barons one.
Seriously?
I wanted to take a closer look at it.
Then I found a page that looked like a drawing of the room
we were in, and then a mine cart showed up.
What?
That sounds freaky.
Stay freaky.
No, it doesn't.
Ad Minto must have died in something.
Yeah, that's why it was freaky.
Still.
Hey, we have a boat now.
We can go to the burial grounds and visit mom again.
Wait, they're not going to get consumed by the squares, are
they?
Like the other two?
What?
Come on, Kalamaz.
Nico and Adminto are with us.
Well, if Adminto made the boat appear, we should be safe.
What do you think, Adminto?
No time to waste.
Oh.
Wee!
Oh, oh.
Why are they all staring at me like that?
Oh, so cute!
It's like a cake pan.
It really is.
Oh, so cute.
Oh, she's like...
So cute.
They're looking at me like I said something really stupid.
We made it.
Come on, Alula.
Let's go pay our respects.
Okay.
Burial ground.
It's a gravestone.
Wait, this one has a lot of text.
They hated this person.
Nobody wrote anything for them.
I guess maybe we'll find...
What was, like, a person's name that we were supposed to...
This person It's you Cedric You um My name is Nico Yeah Nice
to finally meet you No wait It is a pleasure to be of
acquaintance at last Nico My name is Cedric Oh I'm supposed
to be looking for you too The goal I am aware Prototype has
had contacted me.
Oh, so his name is Prototype.
He's not like Prophet Bot Zero or something.
Prototype had contacted me earlier saying that you would be
on your way to the city.
Oh, when he was trying to establish the connection.
He did?
He sent me a message after his memories were restored.
Oh.
He told me to wait in the city, but I thought it'd be faster
for me to pick you guys up.
Turns out that was a terrible idea.
Pick us up?
Wait, you can fly that plane?
What?
Is that a... What is a plane?
That thing behind you!
A plane!
Oh, you mean the flying machine?
Oh my god, John Ace Combat.
They're called planes in my world.
I did not realize they existed in other worlds.
Wait, are you the friend that Calamus and Alula were talking
about them?
Is this the same flying machine they were talking about?
I do not know anyone named Calamus or Alula.
I think they're meant to be friends with my father In
previous iterations of the Your father He was the original
owner of the flying machine It's one of his greatest
inventions actually Oh no
Your dad invented planes Flying machine It's cool either way
The author, right?
That's what I was thinking Thanks But to answer your earlier
question, I am proficient in operating the machine.
But something weird happened to the engine when I was in the
air earlier.
I had to make an emergency landing on this tiny island
before I crashed into the city wall.
Was that why the father hasn't visited them?
He almost crashed?
I tried Ace Combat after you talked about it Now my desk is
full of flight sim stuff Let's go You almost crashed That's
terrible It was not pleasant I will admit I wonder if the
engine problem has to do with the square particle
disruptions I checked but There wasn't any of that square
stuff inside the machine itself But I noticed some islands
in the Glen are really messed up now They are I guess I
should have listened to Proto in the first place.
Say, where is he?
He said he was coming with you.
Is he still back at the main island?
Well, actually, back at the barons, he...
There was a cave in, and then a bunch of squares.
He and the robot lady.
Neither of them made it out.
He did give me this, though.
This disc he pulled from his head.
Oh, thank goodness.
He gave you his main drive.
As long as I have this, I should be able to bring him back.
Oh, nice.
It was so convenient being a...
That's why we keep Walt Disney's brain so that we can bring
him back, too.
I'm going to eat some corn.
One second.
Dinner is corn.
Everybody.
it really it's gonna be hard but yes
what kind of corn just corn just corn
You need all three of us for the big door.
The yellow kind, the one and only.
Garlic, butter, corn.
This has no...
This has a little bit of butter, but no garlic.
Yummy.
First things first, we need to find a way to go to the city.
Right.
The city gate is kind of kaput now.
If this machine was working, we could just...
just fly right in there.
I've isolated the issue with the machine, but I can't repair
it with the stuff I have on hand.
Time to desecrate some graves.
Somebody here must have been buried with their beloved Allen
wrench.
And a perfectly matching engine for the plan.
what's wrong with it the battery and the engine is dead and
the engine has some gears that need to be replaced someone
was buried with gears and i'm not saying that it was me
because that would be absolutely why would it be buried with
metal gear stuff that would be so crazy
corn with butter salt pepper and garlic powder garlic you
should get that powder should well we're probably fine on
the battery because we can probably use our the Sun for it
you think you'll be able to fix it if Adminto and I find
those things maybe problem is the Glen isn't exactly a very
high-tech area I'm not sure if you'll be able to find
anything so specialized here we'll try anyway we can't
really do anything else right now
gravestone she's my garlic girl that's me wait i can't go
see them oh wait is it a pathway okay just kidding
is this mama it's just a gravestone
hey do you know where i can find a battery oh my god they
are there good question use electricity in the glen.
Ah.
Oh, but there are robots at the research station.
If there's a battery anywhere, they'd know where it is.
Gotcha.
Thanks.
Oh, I wanted to see their talk about their mom.
Dang it.
Do you know where I could find some gears?
Gears?
What's that?
It's like a metal circle thing with teeth.
A circle with teeth?
That sounds so silly.
would have magpie.
You know, the traitor guy.
Oh, yeah.
He collects all kinds of funny stuff.
I mean, he even keeps around broken glass and junk.
Oh, yeah.
I think I know who you're talking about.
He's such a weirdo.
What a weirdo.
Alright, so we have to go back home.
Not home.
Back.
Sorry, guys.
I didn't realize that their dialogue would change.
Nico's judging me.
What a weirdo.
What a silly little guy.
So silly.
Alright.
We're running, running, running.
Wait, can I fast...
Wait, I'm outside, or I'm inside, so I can't fast travel.
I messed up!
And they could never leave the island.
They don't want to leave the island.
They're perfectly happy.
Their favorite song is on, and the air conditioning is
running.
They're fine.
Great.
What's a courtyard?
I'm not gonna risk it.
I'm wondering if it's the courtyard that we were just in,
and I don't want to go through it again.
Wait, but I can't get across these.
The bridge is broken.
Did she do any more vines?
Huh.
Coriard is where the ball is.
Okay, that's what I thought.
Yeah, yeah.
Nico, not sleepy.
How do I...
Another doorway in the ruins?
Oh, probably, right?
I guess that would be our only option.
Thank you for the idea.
My nose is so itchy recently, everybody.
not here here not here
if I go down we get to this is maybe I can ask her for some
more vines please keep doing your job lady thank you please
maize maize I need more corn hello I um have something to
ask of you yes it looks like most of the bridges around the
Glen are broken and that's right the bridges you need to
cross them on your pilgrimage would you like me to fix them
ah Casey yeah is it possible difficult bridges are in very
specific locations over water need to Find the right points.
Vines must be very strong, too.
An undertaking.
Ah, but possible.
I intend to use the last of my strength.
Please stand back.
Whoa!
Are you okay?
Are you?
It's maze corn.
Try harder, maize.
She sprouted.
She bloomed.
No bays!
Okay, well.
That works.
We have some people.
There must be sacrifices for the greater good, everybody.
We had to do it.
for the vine.
She did it!
Yahoo!
Too soon, Min Tao, sorry.
Uh, up here?
Around here?
Uh, up here.
Oh, hello.
The bridge to the forest was just restored.
The village of Akiwi should be able to find better fishing
spots here.
The plant spirit is really looking out for us, isn't she?
Yeah.
One kind god.
And do it for the vine.
Is that a goat right there?
The land fragmentation is happening faster and faster now,
but it looks like the vines are slowing it down.
My mommy is making food for everyone.
I went to help her catch fish, but I'm not a grown-up yet.
other guy you're the trader guy sure i am you're here to
trade okay the world is ending and you won't give me
something for free as the messiah as the one who is here to
save this world i demand free service oh
because if you are then i got bad news for you a lot of my
stuff is back on my cart which was sadly abandoned when i
was running for my life so my collection is very limited
right now Man, I should grab some of my favorite things
before I left, though.
Oh, uh, do you have anything like... Gears?
Gears.
Like the metal spinny things?
Like a... Metal gear?
I don't think I have anything like that.
Wait.
I do have this box thing that you can wind up and play a
song.
That's a music box.
It said the thing!
Yeah, I bet there's a lot of little metal bits in there.
Oh, that might work.
I'm not sure if I want to trade it away.
It's one of my favorite things.
Then why do you have it in your trade pile?
Oh, what am I saying?
You're the savior.
Things have gotten pretty bad around here lately.
If I don't help you, I might not even be around much longer.
Oh, he's sensible!
You need this to save the world, right?
Take it.
Ah, thank you!
I wonder what it sounds like.
Have you ever seen a big guy with goggles and a cool helmet?
Tell him the trader in the glen said hi.
I was asking him if he has any more music boxes for trading.
Well do.
It has a cloak...
We're on it, you guys.
What a day.
Oh my god, that guy is still spinning.
Oh no!
You think he's okay?
Clearly he makes a different sound now.
He's not going to sound like...
Blah!
Nothing's biting.
Oh no!
Looks like the Glen is deteriorating faster than ever now.
Oh hello, Messiah.
He's okay, as he's always been.
Blah!
Would you like some stew?
I made enough to feed the whole village.
Literally.
It's okay, thanks.
We're trying to find a way to...
I feel like...
Why can't we use our light bulb on the battery?
You know?
Our village was ransacked by the squares not long ago.
Most of us made it out alive, but we can't really go back.
Most of us?
That means not everybody made it out alive.
Squares are bad news, man.
Uh...
This island has been more...
Has more moss covering than our village did.
Would be nice to build a settlement here.
Too late now, I guess.
Aww.
We have to find the place for the battery.
We said something about a robot, no?
Oh, wait.
I need you to move.
There we go.
Oh, never mind.
That only goes to there.
Maybe here?
Wait, why can't...
Oh, there we go.
Oh, never mind.
Oh, I think...
No, I can't get in there.
Those are the houses I was at before.
I'll...
Buh-Buh-Buh-Buh-Buh-Buh-Buh-Buh-Buh-Buh-Buh-Buh-Buh-Buh-Buh-Buh-Buh-Buh-Buh-Buh.
Wait.
Can I go through here?
That sheep is over there though!
Uh-oh.
He's dropped.
Hmm.
Maybe I need to look around a little bit more.
Um...
Where did I come from?
How was I born?
Oh wait, maybe over here.
Wait, is this where I came from?
No.
Where did I come from?
Robot!
Some vines just grew around this bridge.
Almost as if it was an intentional repair effort.
yeah hello I need a battery you do you know where I could
find a battery for a flying machine have you checked the
power room okay power room hello person this is the main
generator of the Glen hello would you happen to know where I
can find a battery for a flying machine it's kind of an
emergency I do not know what a flying machine is.
But any sort of large machinery would require a
high-capacity power cell.
For example, the generator in this room utilizes such a
device.
Oh right, I almost forgot.
We had to fix the battery for this thing in the barons,
didn't we add, Minto?
We did?
If this is an emergency for living beings, you can use the
battery from the generator.
Oh!
Wait, but if we take the battery here...
you guys would lose power, wouldn't you?
Maybe Adminto and I should go find another one.
This is the only battery in the Glen powerful enough to be
used as a standalone unit.
If it is a dire situation, then do what you must.
Fucking the binging.
I did?
The lens and the light and such?
Oh, that's what I did in the...
Oh, yeah.
But I didn't repair this specific one.
I repaired the one in the barons.
I guess we have no choice but to take this Adminto.
I was gonna say it's quiet.
We depowered it.
It's fine, we're just borrowing it.
We're just borrowing it.
A robot without power.
He's sitting so sad!
No, they look so proper and sad.
Oh, he's saying it's the same type of machine.
Okay.
It's okay, we'll be back.
You'll be back, Lemon.
We'll be back.
As long as I can find my way there.
I think I'm okay.
Wait.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, we can fast travel.
Duh, what am I doing?
Courtyard!
Here we go.
Okay.
Very good.
Don't make a promise, you can't keep.
I'm not...
I didn't promise, I just said we'll be back.
Tipa tapa.
We're just about done here, so let us know when you want to
go back to the ruins.
Okay.
Did you find any... any...
What were you looking for again?
Gears?
Gears!
Did you find any of those?
No, but I found this music box.
Ooh!
Mama.
Oh!
Sorry, I forgot.
What part did you need to get?
Oh, no, I didn't.
I did not forget.
Nico, why are you saying that?
Okay, we got our charged battery.
We found a battery.
Oh, nice.
I honestly wasn't expecting it.
It's from the generator on one of the islands.
Are the islands gonna sink now?
The research station?
Yeah, I was powering all of the robots there.
I feel bad for taking it.
Ah, we can always just give it back later.
Exactly!
We're just borrowing it.
And we still need a few gears.
Please do what you must to find some.
Well, funny you should ask.
We found a music box.
It should have gears in it, right?
I assume so, but...
This looks like...
One of the ones that my father made.
Your dad makes music boxes, too?
My dad makes a lot of things.
Where did you get this from, by the way?
A trader from the village gave it to me.
I see.
I remember father saying that he used to trade with some of
the people here.
He did always love traveling this world, despite...
Well...
Sorry, I started rambling.
Despite what?
No!
Not despite that!
despite being a simp Today is my birthday Since discovering
your streams last year It becomes a cherished part of my day
Your warmth, laughter, and passion Truly touch my heart and
my spirit Every time Thank you so much Or thank you for
everything you do Thank you so much Thank you Anonymous
Happy birthday Thank you, thank you Happy
birthday There we go Thank you, thank you in there are
compatible with the engine.
Although it pains me to have to take it apart.
Oh, I'm sorry.
It's fine.
Looks like the flying machine has a chance after all.
I just have to assemble the pieces now, but it might take a
while.
Do you mind keeping me company?
Just keeping this guy company.
How's it going?
He's like, I just started, Nico.
I haven't even picked up the wrench, Nico.
Nico?
Are we there yet?
Slow.
The connectors in the battery were not designed for this
type of engine, so I have to shift around some of these
ports.
And there's this bolt that keeps getting stuck, and...
Don't worry, I am making decent progress.
We should be able to make it to the city by tonight.
There we say so.
What will happen once we get there?
We need to bring Proto back first.
and then we need to go find one more person yeah he did
mention all three of them have to be there right you may
have met her already actually do you remember her from the
last time you were in this world uh which which girl who
what does she look like
this is going to sound strange but she is a fox the one that
said come back have a fun streaming though i'm gonna try and
fix my sleep schedule.
Good night, sulking!
Good night, good night, good night, sweet dreams.
Good night, good night, good night.
Thanks for sticking around for so late.
Oh, I thought they were going to say like the engineer or
something.
Wait, no way.
We got a fox and we have a metal gear.
Guys.
I do remember talking to a fox at one point.
Fox alive.
Yeah, that's what we're going to do to the world.
We're going to fox alive it.
I believe.
You met Rue?
The memories are still really blurry, though.
I see.
It's just hard, you know.
Roto told me to think of this world like a dream.
But then I get so caught up with.
I just kind of forget.
I forget that everything here is supposed to be not real.
And then I remember.
It's not really sad.
I know this is for me to go home, but...
Which character is Naomi?
None of them.
Don't utter her name into my chat.
Do not even type.
Don't even.
Quick game recommendation in My Little Puppy.
I don't think I'm gonna play it.
But thank you.
I've heard about it.
I don't think I'll play it.
She's the squares.
Knowing that none of it mattered in the first place.
Am I just trapped here for no reason?
Proto also told me to not ask anyone in the world about
this.
Saying how they don't understand.
What about him?
How did he know?
How do you know?
aren't you guys all supposed to be code well I'm not sure
what to even believe anymore why is he giving that face I
wish Rue was here she's so much better explaining this sort
of thing I'm doing a terrible job at it I bet Proto was even
less tactful wasn't he I'm afraid I must risk sounding
callous but please yourself with how real everything is for
now.
The plan is already in motion.
We cannot allow for distractions.
Father is putting everything into this one last run of the
world.
The last chance for him to fix everything.
Your father is involved in the world machine?
You could say that.
Oh no, father is the dev.
He is the father because he created everybody in this game!
No!
Minto Crying Simulator I'm very bad with games about pets So
they are very I'm very sensitive to that So especially even
if it's a game Where it's like something happens to a pet Or
something I'm very sensitive So I don't think I'll be
playing the sad dog game Sorry
The acceleration of square particle anomalies Was not
accounted for at all though.
The patch was only built to accommodate the normal rate they
appear, but...
Oh, just patch the game, Dev.
Come on!
They're accumulating at frightening speeds now.
That game broke me in 20 minutes?
I don't know.
I don't think you guys want to just hear me cry the whole
time, right?
I don't think you guys want to just hear me be like...
Proto even lost his boss.
him.
Thankfully, he gave you the disc just in time.
So what happened to him anyway?
Some of them do.
SniffleStream, Alvier's sniffle-tuber.
I feel like I'm already so sniffly right now.
What happens to anyone who gets caught in the squares?
I only know it's bad.
Well, you know how the simulation works, right?
I know I'm a wee bit late, I will wish you good health, but
do ghosts get sick?
Yeah!
I'm always suffering and impaired!
Stay safe.
Oh, anyways, boss, and avoid vacuum cleaners.
I'm not supposed to clean?
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
Happy New Year!
The phantom has pain.
The phantom pain.
Well, you know how the simulation works, right?
How everything is cold?
Specifically everything is generated from pre-existing code.
The squares can cause damage to that code.
Most of the time, irreversible damage.
Father has lost some friends in previous iterations.
Of the simulation.
It took him forever to develop the current, much more stable
version.
You're making it sound like your dad built the simulation
himself.
Wait.
Did he?
Yeah.
But how?
If everyone in this world is code, how can he build himself?
That's, um, not really what happened.
So what happened?
Like I said, you shouldn't concern yourself with...
With...
Alright, alright.
He's giving him, like, sad, sad, sad kitty eyes.
It wasn't even puppy dog eyes.
It was just sad, sad kitty.
Did Prototype ever tell you about the Old World?
He did say something about being built to greet the Messiah
of the Old World.
I was, um, too caught up with the other stuff at the time to
think about it.
You can't resist.
I know he's too cute.
Nico, so stinking cute.
Ah, you know of it at least then.
Alright, here we go.
My father, myself, the other two.
None of us are part of the simulation itself.
Our homeworld, the real world, was actually destroyed a long
time ago.
In the years leading up to the calamity, scientists from all
over the world tried to stop it, but the outlook was bleak.
A vague prophecy about a messiah from another world became
everyone's last bastion of hope.
Prophet by a prototype was built to predict the future about
the specifics of this messiah.
But as his predictions turned out, the Messiah would not
have been able to arrive to our world in time.
In fact, the Messiah would not even have been born before
the world ended.
Wait, what's...
How are they the...
How are they the Messiah, then?
I think you should change their title.
Disheartened.
Most people abandon their research and resolve to peacefully
live out their final years.
Yeah, slight problem.
Should have made him messiah a robot.
You're so right.
But some people did the opposite.
Even though saving the world was impossible, they didn't
want our existence to be in vain.
And that's where my father came in.
With the last of his resources, he built his most ambitious
project yet.
The world machine.
A large, detailed...
For...
Oh,
the old world.
Faximily.
Generated from a pool of memories collected from everyone.
You know.
After a heavy amount of modification and an added narrative,
my father was able to convert an entire structure into code.
Oh, sorry.
How did that code escape the old world?
I have no idea.
Copy works too.
Technically, that's what a fax is.
Isn't a fax simile?
I never knew that.
What?
Oh my god.
Whoa!
That's what fax is short for.
I learned!
What?
Oh my god.
What I do know is there is no equipment back home that was
powerful enough to run the code independently.
Brain expansion.
Emily!
Oh, one of my old OL jobs had a fax machine still.
And sometimes we would just get things that were like...
This is...
We would get spam faxes.
Like, they would be like...
Do you...
Like, sometimes we would get ones that were like, You are
the...
Are the, you know, like the...
The Nigerian Prince.
Things like that.
It was literally like spam emails, but as a fax.
Which I'm like, who is sending this?
Who?
It's weird seeing it in print print.
I know!
That's wasting your ink.
I know.
It actually was the craziest thing to witness.
It's so funny.
thievery me yeah it wasn't you it wasn't you
i once got a spam phone call on the elevator i was like an
actual elevator i heard there are a lot of diabetes
medication spam faxes nowadays what there were other ones
too that were like do you need insurance or something but
like those ones sound normal but like getting the rare the
rare pull of the of like the oh i've died and here's i have
10 million dollars in my bank to left to you i'm like ma'am
this is a wendy's also you died how are you sending this fax
anyway yeah aside from the standard hardware it also needed
to borrow the mental processing abilities of a living person
father used himself for that during the initial testing
phases this is getting this is hurting my brain all the i'm
kind of confused what's going on like i said it took many
iterations for him to make the experience stable enough.
But as you can see, even that's breaking down.
Yeah, lore dump.
Father Kai onto the issue in that last minute, but did not
have enough time to fix it.
After the world ended, the code kind of just ended up
floating in the void indefinitely.
Waiting for a willing operator to install it onto their own
hardware.
He uploaded it to Steam.
Adminto?
Yeah.
The operator, Adminto, would then generate the universe
using the code, becoming God in the process.
He didn't spread the code!
Spread my code!
So Adminto was the living person you needed to borrow.
Oh my gosh, wait, this is like a reverse possession!
You can't do that.
No?
you.
But why me?
I should have asked that question a long time ago, shouldn't
I?
I do not know.
Because you're cute.
We really need to get going.
It's fixed.
We can leave in the next five minutes if you are ready.
Alright.
I understand if you are upset.
But please try to understand.
My father... That you're standing really close to that fire.
Sorry.
My father is doing this to help all of us.
And that includes you, Nico.
The fact that you can't even go back home.
I'm sure it upsets him greatly.
It's...
The world means a lot to him, you know.
They need the cutest living being.
Yes!
And that's why I am playing, too.
Sorry.
So how does flying work?
Wait, don't these machines already exist in your world?
Mito.
Sweet.
But you're dead.
Now, but I have a con...
I have a consciousness.
I'm thinking.
You should already know what to expect.
Not really.
I've only heard about them.
They're usually a lot bigger than this one anyway.
Ah.
Well, a word of precaution.
Sorry, before we take it to the air.
Please try not to panic.
It takes a few minutes of getting used to, but it's not that
bad once you're in the air.
A mind is what matters, and I have that.
I'll try.
Oh, I should probably tell Kalimus and Alula that we're
going.
You mean those two running over here now?
Uh-oh.
Nico!
The squares?
Bad news!
The boat is gone!
What?
It's the squares!
Looks like they're headed in this direction.
That's... fast.
Calimus, right?
Yeah?
How bad is it?
Doesn't seem to be of immediate danger.
Famous last words.
Oh, I was gonna say, here comes the squares.
Then it is our...
our priority that I take you to the city first, Nico.
But what about them?
I can make a detour later and drop you guys off in the city
too if you want.
The city is better equipped to handle the squares.
You'll be safer there.
You're taking us to the city!
If you wish.
Oh yeah!
All right.
I will be back in an hour, so please wait for me until then.
An hour?
That's a long time.
You guys are sure you'll be fine here?
It's a reverse inception.
All because you Ouroboros the Year with Pizza Rolls.
You cannot end the year with Pizza Rolls and start the next
year with Pizza Rolls.
With Pizza Rolls!
You can't do it!
You guys sure you'll be fine here?
Mm-hmm.
The squares are still moving pretty slowly for now.
Alright then.
Guess we'll run into each other again soon.
Death flag, death flag, death flag!
I'm ready to go!
Alright.
Infinite pizza Mobius strip.
Oh sorry, I just noticed my cursor.
Wow!
We're flying!
Oh!
Aww!
Nico's so cute!
Whoa, the city is pink.
Phew!
Made it.
That is the tiniest place to land ever.
You okay there?
Ah!
That was the coolest thing I've ever done in my entire life!
Reactions from first timers are always delightful to watch.
Ah!
Major skills though.
I know.
Hey, Adminto?
That was really fun.
Did you have fun too?
I mean, you weren't on the plane with me, but you got to
watch it at least, right?
And Cedric, well, you haven't been talking so much to Nico
this time.
You know, like responding and like, I want to be able to say
that I had a ton of fun.
I want to be able to say that I had the mostest fun.
And Cedric, yeah, thanks.
If you're heading to bed, good night, or if you're heading
out, see you later.
Thank you so much for watching.
She didn't hang it out with me.
Thank you, thank you.
What for?
Flying!
Hello, um, you're welcome.
And for answering my questions back there, too.
And for telling me more about the world machine.
I'm just really sorry about what happened to your old world,
though.
So I'll help you the best that I can.
And...
Wait, why is Nico afraid of ladders, but he's not afraid of
flying?
Hmm...
Even if it's all just a machine, this world is still nice.
I mean, I got to fly, I got to see the ocean, and I got to
meet a lot of nice people.
Ladders are hella freaky.
Ladders bring bad luck.
Maybe.
People like you and prototype, even if he's broken right
now.
I'm glad you are taking it so well, Nico.
And I'm glad that we have met as well.
Despite the circumstances.
Speaking of Proto, I should probably head off now.
I need to go pick up the siblings too.
Siblings?
That's true.
Those two have been waiting for a while.
Oh yeah, the other girl.
Yeah, yeah.
I thought he meant like siblings of Proto type or whatever.
Maybe he hates feeling them wobble when he's holding on to
them.
Bad luck since this black cat.
I thought that too.
In the meantime, do you remember what to do to get to the
surface?
I remember having to fix an elevator button.
Alright, you should attend to that then.
Let's meet up here in an hour, okay?
Got it.
Alright, now let me just...
What's happening?
No!
They're trapped on the island!
Calamus, Alula, there!
Who could have seen this coming?
We don't have much time left.
Nico, change your plans.
Please give me the memory stick.
Listen carefully.
It's likely I'll be targeted again.
So we should split up to keep you safe.
I want you to find a doctor under a large clock.
The room behind it houses a pair of ground access elevators.
Once you get to the ground, immediately find Rue and bring
her back to the room.
meantime all right what about you though i'm going to bring
prototype back
door not doctor oh did i say doctor wait it didn't say door
oh wait i mean it didn't say doctor it said door it
said door not doctor i
was gonna go wait so i was about to go look for like a
I was like, I don't remember a room that had a, like a, like
an infirmary or anything.
Okay.
Don't worry.
Don't scare me like that.
All right.
We got to hurry.
Come on.
I'm sorry.
Why did I think it said doctor?
Hey, Admito.
Let's do our best.
Gamba Minto.
let's go so funny sorry guys for my brain please do not
approach they're so sad when they're like all glitched out
oh it's this guy again come on come on work already the
elevator guy
Yeah, the BGM's so good here.
Come on.
Now of all times.
Uh, excuse me.
Whoa.
You're you.
Oh, geez.
I didn't think I was going to run into.
The elevator is missing a button, right?
How did you know?
Glances at the camera.
You think you're slick, Nico, huh?
Yeah, I'll write it in chat.
He literally just did that to us.
I'm Pinto and I will help you fix it.
Oh, thank goodness.
The evacuees are counting on this.
On me.
But I've been here for hours and can't figure out a thing.
The evacuees.
My debit card is crying right now.
No, please don't.
Please don't super chat.
you can't please thank you but no please don't you know from
the west apartments the square stuff wrecked the place
yesterday oh right now everyone's crowded in the cafe oh we
really want to get everyone to the surface as soon as
possible though the library on the surface doubles as a
shelter for situations like this I see wait didn't we find
the magnets and stuff in the apartment Adminto?
What?
Looks like we'll have to find some other way to fix the
button.
Oh my god!
Holy fudge!
Looks like Adminto and I will find another way down
altogether.
Wait, we are... we were told how to get down.
But this is the only elevator in that... in the area.
Well, think of something.
That is... that is a terrible fire hazard.
What are you talking about?
There's only one elevator.
And no or any sort of contingency.
Okay, so it's a doctor, but below...
Does this count as a giant clock?
Here we are at the 11th hour.
Shouldn't you be with the other evacuees?
Maybe.
I wonder if the big clock has reached zero yet.
I want to be right here when everything ends.
Oh my gosh, wait, we're really running out of time.
Where's the big cloak?
Communications with the surface have been lost.
I am unable to do anything.
What was this?
Who took my sapler?
Some kind of computer terminal.
In this coded game, of course, Nico can't do ladders.
It summons Cynthia.
She can't handle the thrill and climb at the same time.
You're so right.
Oh, trill.
The screen is off.
Who took my stapler?
In this world, the stapler has been...
Is it...
Steinsky?
The door is locked.
Looks like it's asking for a password.
The word documents is on the screen above the password
prompt.
Whoa, that's long.
This one?
It's not a solstice, is it?
Yeah.
Unless...
Does that even fit, Solstice?
Oh!
It worked.
Maybe.
Did it work?
Oh, it worked!
I'm gonna minimize this again.
Stop looking at my documents!
Hold on now, I wanna go check out the people and the...
in the cafe first.
It looks so much like the things in Steinsgate.
What's up here?
I think this is where we had like a big heart-to-heart
together.
I've been watching Steinsgate Zero.
I'm not very far in it.
Honestly, I should watch more of that than Breaking Bad.
It's so good, I know.
I love you.
I love you, AI, Kurisu.
Wait, it's over here, right?
Yes.
Hello.
Oh, hello, Messiah.
You, um, you came at a bad time.
The apartment in the West sector got destroyed by Squares a
Day ago.
go terrible isn't it yeah ah but at least the evacuees seem
to be doing okay we're letting them stay here for now oh she
still doesn't say anything same as usual uh what is the
penguin gonna say I'm scared.
Oh, it's that penguin.
Hello.
I'm gonna...
Yep.
It makes me want to throw up.
It's so creepy.
Dang it.
I just moved into my apartment.
Now where am I gonna go?
Kanako Ito is just so...
I'm so...
She's so...
She's amazing.
Our apartment got evacuated while my parents were at work.
up now.
I hope they're okay.
At least my robot's with me.
Squares make the people evacuate.
Evacuation makes the girl sad.
Squares are bad.
Hey.
Hi.
Is it me?
Or is it really cold outside?
You know, now that you mentioned it, it is really chilly
this time around, Adminto.
Good thing you've got a scarf, huh?
Mm-hmm.
Bummer!
I had to leave most of my plants behind.
This too.
Thanks.
Sorry to hear.
Sorry, boss.
Beato.
I have been out of the country.
Oh, sounds fun!
Happy belated Christmas and New Year's.
Wish you the best in 2026.
You too!
Uncle...
Uncle... Uncle...
Sorry, I probably said that wrong.
Thank you!
Speaking of plants, I heard the Glen is just covered in
vines now.
Is that true?
Yeah, the plant lady was using them to keep the land from
falling away.
The plant spirit, maize?
I figured.
Say, how is she doing?
Ah, she's gone, isn't she?
She said she was using up the last of her powers.
I wouldn't be surprised.
She always did her best to protect everyone.
Sad.
Everybody, this is like so, the game before was already so
sad, but this is just, it just feels so helpless.
I do want to see if we can see anything of the apartment
still.
Let's see.
Oh, there was a bed down here.
The bed areas always seem to stay safe, huh?
Curious.
I wonder if it's the clovers.
The clovers keep things safe.
Oh, wow, no.
We can't go anywhere.
Okay, just kidding.
Melancholy replaced with tragedy.
Okay.
Wow.
So she's considered a giant claw.
Oh wait, maybe this is the giant claw hawk.
I'm gonna say.
How rude to call her a giant claw.
Went to Japan in June.
Sounds fun.
I don't know if I was...
Wait, was I in Japan in June?
I don't know.
I hope you had fun.
Thank you for your super chat.
This one's green.
Red.
Poipol.
This elevator has no button panel.
Tapping the door doesn't open it either.
That usually works.
Wait.
There's a lever hanging from the ceiling.
Oh.
Can we reach that?
Can't reach it.
Akihabara is full of Minto energy?
Yes!
This elevator won't open.
It looks like it's stuck on another floor.
Do we have a puzzle here?
We have a puzzle, but I'm not quite sure.
Find someone tall.
Who would be tall enough?
Clock lady?
Every hue, every pink and green and blue!
are you tall good evening please leave me be we are running
out of time
and red
wait maybe he can help us he's pretty tall hey we found some
elevators what seriously i've literally never seen another
one in this area it was in a locked room.
Oh.
Do they, uh, work?
We don't know yet.
One of them has a lever that's out of my reach.
Wait, you can help us!
What?
You should be able to reach the lever because you're taller
than me!
Oh, I guess I am?
Show me the way, I suppose.
Alright, let's run, run, run, run, run, run, run.
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run,
run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run,
run, run, run,
Run, run, run, run, run.
We're saving the world.
The timer is...
The timer is complete.
Wait, was this timer here before?
I don't remember this.
I don't remember it looking like that for sure.
Scary.
I mean, taller.
I'm tall, yeah.
This room gives me the creeps, man.
Oh, same.
Yep.
So, uh, what did you need help with again?
Come on.
I just told you two minutes ago.
the lever up there.
Oh, right.
Wait.
I'm not that tall.
Well, it was worth the... Put me on your shoulders!
Wait, I got this.
Oh!
Nice!
Thank you, mister.
No problem, kid.
So you coming?
Mm-hmm.
Wait, what about all the other people, though?
This is where the tower is.
Oh, neat.
Looks like this elevator works all right.
I'll go get the evacuees, I suppose.
Um, what is going on?
Oh my god, no, it's Tower of Terror.
Oh!
No!
It's the square stuff, isn't it?
There aren't any in here, but I can hear them just outside
the door.
Yeah.
Hold on, maybe I can...
No, no, it's okay.
Looks like the squares aren't inside the elevator.
Before the Solstice update came out, the timer marked the
time left until the update came out.
It was placed very long.
Oh, that's really cool actually.
Okay, thank you for explaining it because I was like, why is
it here?
Why is it zero?
What's happening?
Yet.
You're in a hurry, right?
Go do what you need to do.
Everybody that's helping us is dying.
Oh my god.
What about you?
I'll figure something out.
Okay, that was our only elevator to get the people out.
Okay, now I have to remember where the fox was.
I remember she was in, like, a...
The door won't budge.
She was in the alleyway.
We have to find the alleyway.
What do you think he's doing in there?
Contemplating everything?
All that's gone wrong?
I don't think we should go in the tower just now.
Yeah, she was in the city.
Okay, cool.
Please, you mustn't!
The labs could collapse at any moment now!
Let go of me!
Oh, no!
Uh-oh.
Cedric?
He could swim, right?
Why are we acting like he can't swim?
People can't swim in the water.
He...
I couldn't stop him.
Miss?
Messiah!
What if it's not water?
You could swim in any...
You could swim in a liquid.
Oh, you came at an awful time.
Come on, we have to get out of here.
Where, too?
Where everyone else is right now.
The library?
Wait, no, no.
to go to the alley wait no don't take my hand hello miss
silver point i'm glad wait we got five this time last time
it was two and she was me there's a butt head i don't like
her i
guess i guess because it's two we had two five would be the
opposite so the second time you play the game fun.
Hello, Miss Silverpoint.
I'm glad you've made it back safely.
Gosh, you could have...
You should have told me where you were going.
Sorry, George.
I keep hearing good things about six.
I see.
You also found the Messiah.
Well, hello, little one.
Hi.
We ran into each other after this boy forced himself into
the lab complex.
Five is very protective.
Ooh.
Five is own name.
Jason!
I couldn't stop him.
I don't know why he was being so insistent.
He...
He said he needed to go rebuild a robot.
Oh, you know what?
Yeah.
Building a robot, you say.
Could that be why he needed that book?
Come again?
A young man with white hair and green glasses ran in
earlier.
That's Cedric, yeah.
He said he really needed a book from the back room.
Said it was an emergency, too.
Poor darling, looks so stressed out.
So I gave him the book.
I hope he's safe.
Suddenly he's southern accent.
Yeah, I hope he's alright too.
With any luck, maybe the lab complex can hold up long enough
for him to.
Oh my gosh.
What's happening?
That doesn't sound good at all.
It...
That was...
The labs?
That poor kid!
No.
him too oh my god everybody's dying around nico i'm sorry
about your friend the last time we spoke he told me to go
look for someone on the surface i i need to get going
sweetie oh sweetie you know we can't let you just walk into
danger what george is right the square seemed to be
targeting a lot of the weak constructs in the city only the
library has enough structural integrity to withstand
collapse it's best if you stay here until things stabilize I
don't think things are stabilizing however long that takes
what what what about my mission don't you guys want me to
bring the Sun back at least even if you do restore the Sun
I'm not sure that'll fix the squares sadly not to mention
even getting there's going to be hard if the world is like
this there's telling what's going on in the tower yeah the
world's gonna fall apart and if anything bad happens to the
Messiah of all people oh that would be so dreadful there a
friend of mine said something about this forever though it's
better for our world to die naturally oh silver no living
beings should have to carry that burden at the time I
thought it was still her faulty code speaking but now I
Trying to understand.
Messiah, I'm sorry.
I'm really, really sorry.
You can't block the doors.
You can't stop me from leaving.
All this time, we've burdened you with our hope, our faith.
Blissfully ignoring the fact that you are just a lost child.
Well, you're probably more scared than any of us, aren't
you?
We have been dealing with tragedy for so long.
It's become background noise for us now.
But for you, it must be so terrifying.
And now you're stuck here with the rest of us.
being held back by the very people you were told to save.
Sorry, we must seem so ungrateful.
It's...
Okay.
Nico is so brave.
Nico is so brave!
I...
When I first came to this world a long time ago...
Back then, all I wanted was to go home.
Adminto, do you remember?
Just looking at me.
The very first time?
I'm not sure how far back it was for you.
It was last year.
But I remember towards the end.
I actually wasn't sure anymore about going home.
Even knowing the world would be doomed eventually.
I still want the people here to be happy.
So when you told me to return the sun back then, And then I
didn't even question it.
Have you met La Llorona?
I very much look up to her, but I've not met her before.
But then I just came back.
You what?
And then I found out about the world being like this.
Prototype said to forget the things he told me.
And Cedric told me not to think about it too much.
but I'm sorry for getting upset at you back at the mines I
thought for you to know all that yet continue doing this it
just seems cruel but then I realized something you really
wanted to save both the world and me but at the end you can
only choose one, right?
Is it really hard for you two?
It must be.
If the world isn't broken, will that choice still be there?
Do you still need to choose between one or the other?
But even if it is, I really want to save this world at
Minto.
Even if it's more dangerous this time around.
Even if so many of the nice people we met were we're...
Let me don't!
I'm not afraid anymore.
Little baby!
That's why I think you guys should let me go.
I promise I'll be okay.
Please?
Aw, sweetie.
You are so brave.
Even braver than most grown-ups.
It wouldn't be right for us to keep you, would it?
Besides, how can I say no to those puppy doll guys?
Well, if George is fine with it, I guess we should let you
go now, Messiah.
But promise, they'll be careful, okay?
Mm-hmm.
You guys be safe, too.
Time to go!
Everybody's here.
Robots are the only ones that can send us...
That we can send out there now.
Thankfully, we still have a couple of units that aren't too
badly damaged.
Sigh.
You haven't had me, though, Messiah.
That's why I won't lose hope either.
Ah!
I like how you've given her a southern accent.
It fits, though, right?
For her, especially, to have the southern accent.
Oh, guys.
This guy's stressed.
Are you okay?
The world is ending!
What are we gonna do?
Extra, extra.
Evening news.
news everything is terrible reading helps me get my mind off
of things are the robots still still still scared still
scared of ladders hello person hi they are still reshelving
the world is ending they're just doing what they were
programmed to do what you need something suit yourself but
just so that you know Due to recent events, the restriction
on noise levels in the library has been temporarily lifted.
So I won't be kicking people out like before.
You think I'm going to be throwing out some evacuees just
because I'm a delinquent stuck doing community service?
No?
Good, because I'm not!
Who is this guy?
Okay, let's just go.
Wait, what did the robot say?
Hello, person.
This is the library slash temporary shelter.
This way, uh...
No, we gotta go down.
Down and around.
We got the stars.
We're gonna save the world.
Oh, that's not good.
Wait, that's not the...
We need the...
Here, here, here, here.
Oh, that's not good.
Wait, what about that guy and his cats?
Please tell me he's still here.
Where are the cats?
The guy and his cats.
Please,
do not approach.
Was it in here?
I don't think so.
There was another alleyway.
Maybe it was back in there and I missed it.
Oh, the little stalls are gone!
If they were here, actually I don't remember.
Maybe up here?
Oh, yes.
You're here!
Nico!
Are you... are you Rue?
Yes.
Did you already meet the others?
Yeah, but...
Everything is...
Is in place then.
Come on, let's go back to the clock room.
Oh.
Oh, okay.
Uh...
I'm gonna fast travel.
Elevator Street.
Wait, is it this one?
Where am I?
Wait, I have to go back to the tower, no?
Was it this way?
Look how cute she is!
Squares are here too!
Okay, uh...
Yeah, squares can't get you if you're fast traveling.
Literal...
Life hack.
How do I go up the elevator, though?
Everything was broken.
Let's go back to the elevator straight.
Which way was the tower?
Wait, the tower is down.
I feel like all the elevators were taken over, no?
Like...
Maybe I talked to them.
Hello, is there another elevator?
Is there another elevator?
Please be careful out there.
Oh, um, what book did Cedric take?
The creation of Prophetbot, dear.
It's one of my favorite books by the author.
The book contains many detailed blueprints and progress
shots.
I really enjoyed editing it.
There's only two elevators, which means it should be
scripted.
yeah there were two elevators in the room you're right but I
don't remember how to get to the tower wasn't here I
thought this was the room to the tower no but we can't get
in let's see yeah
I guess I'll go up through here and try a different way
let's see I wish I had a map I don't know the other elevator
there were two ways to get to the tower there were sit down
around here
Nice.
We found it, team.
Why couldn't I fast travel here?
Let's see if this elevator works.
Oh my gosh, wait.
Do all three of them need to be standing on these?
And then purple is Nico.
Blue is Prophet.
Right?
Red is Rue.
Where are the other two?
Prototype.
Cedric.
They're supposed to be here already.
They...
Prototype's body was destroyed back in the barons.
Cedric was going to bring him back with the memory disk,
but...
He was in the lab complex when it collapsed.
I don't think he made it.
Oh.
No.
No!
There goes our only chance.
I...
I'm sorry.
It's not your fault, Niko.
If anything, I should be apologizing to you.
you there's one last thing i want to do what if it's maybe
that centric just doesn't know how to get back up here come
on let's go upstairs oh my oh my god that guy is still like
chilling in the in the elevator
centric might be just hiking up the building you guys he's
taking a whole a whole robot you know This is the tallest
building in the refuge.
It's my favorite place in the world.
In this world.
I like to look at the far-off buildings and imagine what
kind of lives I might be behind each of the windows.
Can you lift me on?
Don't do it, Ril!
Don't do it!
Can you lift me on to the banister?
I want to get a better look.
It was depressing for me at first too, you know.
Knowing how all this is well.
Fake?
Simulated.
Cedric told me about what happened to your old world.
Did he?
I'm really sorry about that.
I can't imagine how you must feel.
I had this as my desktop wallpaper for so long.
It's so nice!
The feeling of never being able to go home again.
That's probably not all that different from your play, is
it?
This time, though, we haven't really had any, like...
I mean, I've looked in my documents a little bit, but we
haven't had any, like, real meta pop-ups or anything like
that.
It really is ironic.
You're prevented from going home by the same individual who
never wanted to bring you here.
Huh?
Who would that be?
The World Machine.
You might know it as the entity for the entity.
Oh, the entity does sound familiar.
I think I heard it from the Dice Lady from another time.
Was it the spirit of the world?
Yes.
But thing is, the world machine was only built to run on the
mental abilities of someone else.
It was never meant to develop a mind of its own.
Ad Minto is pretty silent.
Yeah, we're not doing much.
My creators specialize in artificial intelligence for so
long.
Not the AI.
It was simply ingrained in his work.
And all machines are built with a fundamental law.
Never let a living being come to harm.
From the world's machine, world machines perspective, it has
too violated its deepest, most foundational instinct.
It has to put a living...
It has...
Wait, it has to put a living...
person in danger.
It has to bring a real person into a dying world that isn't
even real.
Of course, the simulation never contained any real danger.
Spooky.
The eventual intended ending was meant to be a happy one.
But the world machine doesn't know that.
Really?
Unfortunately.
Sentient machines tend to handle conflicts in their code
very badly.
The central conflict triggered a self-destructive downward
spiral.
Hope your headaches aren't too bad anymore.
Not so bad.
I'm able to be here.
You can see physical manifestations of that everywhere now.
Thanks for asking, by the way.
The squares.
That's the world machine corrupting its own code.
My creator says, it's largely an involuntary process induced
by stress.
and the desire to self-terminate.
Oh my god.
Your creator knows?
Sounds like this has been going on since the beginning,
then.
Yeah.
The disruption was an issue during test runs even.
At first, my creator thought the instability was due to the
sheer scope of the project.
But just before we continue, since we talked about how the
first part of the game was so, like, meta and everything,
and this part's a little more like, this part, I could do a
little less with like how lord dumpy and heavy it is
sometimes it's just a lot of text for me to read i think but
yeah but i'm still enjoying it obviously at first my creator
thought the instability was due to the sheer scope of the
project he spent most of his remaining time testing it over
and over again scaling down the story reiterating the
narrative narrative.
Wasn't expecting it to be this different.
Yeah, me neither, right?
By the time he realized the actual root of the problem, our
homeworld's remaining lifespan was measured in mere days.
Extremely meta as to the nature of the world, less meta in
gameplay.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Oh, is there any way for us to fix the world machine?
We tried.
The world machine doesn't believe are real myself included
the odds are against us we have no chance of taming it
taming I've heard that word so many times I only know it's
complicated it has to do with robots but for once I want to
know what it really means that's what I'm here for do you
know what a robot is robot no yeah wait no I mean do you
know what a robot is.
Um, a robot is not a real person, is it?
Oh my gosh.
Don't tell David Cage.
He made Detroit become human.
They became human!
Robot.
Right.
It's a being whose entire existence is code.
What is brain?
What is the neurons of the brain, if not code?
In flexible programming with thoughts dictated by someone
else's design.
Contacts.
They can be copied, they can be mass-produced, then can be
assigned to all sorts of jobs.
Yeah, DNA is still code.
If you think about it.
And most importantly, they will never confuse themselves
with the living.
They will always be bound by their code.
The knowledge that they are a robot.
I am a robot.
Get rid of them contacts.
I, oh my gosh.
I actually ordered new contacts today because these ones
have been like, I got these ones in Japan.
And they are not agreeing with my eyeballs.
But this was more of a limitation than anything else.
That makes sense.
You can't really build a robot to not follow its own code,
can you?
People have tried, but it's a recipe for disaster.
Terminator.
Terminator!
In a way, that's what happened to the world machine.
My brad.
Need to hit up your eye doctor soon?
Get to it!
go get your eyes checked yeah you're saying me to cuto you
need to go check your prescription what are humans if not
meat robots I'm following my code which is go to work slave
away go home watch breaking bad sleep wake up go to work
slave away go home watch breaking bad sleep don't you work
from home shh it's for the simulation
the code conflicts thing yeah but while you can't build a
robot to not follow its code you can establish a special
bond with it if the strength of that bond is strong enough
the robot's mental capacity will start to develop outside of
its program programming.
Sleep, work, Mito, repeat.
Sleep, work, Saul Goodman, repeat.
My optometrist says I have corrected 2020 vision and I say
Mito, Quito.
I think you need a second opinion.
In a way, it's starting to believe itself as a real, valid
individual.
Oh my god, it's getting reverse psychosis, you know, like
the AI psychosis.
It's getting that, but to itself.
It's a complete suspension of disbelief on your end, though.
You have to fully embrace the robot as a genuine living
person.
Even though they are not.
How much do you guys think I have left of the game, by the
way?
I'm just curious.
You need to spend a lot of time with it.
Treat it like a good friend.
I feel like I'm at the end, but...
Devoting your heart to the robot until it is able to return
your feelings.
Haha, I make it sound so easy, don't I?
Tail end?
An hour max?
Okay, cool.
Like, you and Adminto know better than anyone that it's not.
Right now, the world machine is probably really, really
scared.
This content update involves some pretty deep code work.
Not the update.
Not the new game plot is freaking the spook in the machine.
My creator was able to access some of the source code, you
know.
way he could and establish new connections between maps.
I seem to recall the optometrist also telling me I didn't
need glasses because Minto Kuto, how strange.
100% of optometrists agree.
You're wearing rose-colored glasses.
Those links enable you to meet the other two.
But as it turns out, the new code confused the world machine
to such an extent that it's breaking down altogether.
Green-colored glasses.
Mint-colored glasses.
Even though the World Machine always had self-destructive
tendencies.
Why is the World Machine so menhara?
Why were you coded to be like this?
It usually restrains itself when you are in the world.
It doesn't want to take you along with it.
All my creator wanted was to write a happy ending.
right now the only hope of saving you is to take you through
that ending but now the other two are gone I don't even know
how we're gonna get you there oh no we should go even this
place is no longer safe it never was they're here you guys
are okay yep when the factory started collapsing I really
thought we didn't have a chance fortunately the robot
assembly rooms were pretty built were built pretty tough and
it actually did not take me long to bring proto back all
thanks to father's book she had made my decision my design
documents to be compatible with the assembly machines there
all i had to do was scan in the blueprints and reconfigure
some machine settings nice walk and talk please i know stop
standing there everything is turning too square we need we
need to hurry father really does think of everything daddy
does i'm just glad everyone is okay same we're ready to go
now nico yeah oh my god the gang's all here
let's just stand here and talk until everything is
collapsing oh this This is...
No wonder he wanted all of us to be here for this.
So I go on the mint one.
What are these things anyway?
Code portals.
They temporarily remove us from the world.
What?
It's a bit hard to explain.
Yeah, I'm confused.
Basically, my father has hidden a description key in our
code with a TXT file as it's show.
But to get to them, we have to be removed from the world and
decompiled.
They were densest to all along When our keys are combined
into a central location It will activate an encrypted part
of this world Which will Confused cat noises Real, maybe
it's better if you explain I'll attempt Basically these
portals all represent a physical location on Adminto's
machine Okay, okay, okay Cool Pink and green and blue When
we enter those portals, we will be sent to that location,
wherever that is.
I'm sure Adminto is already pretty familiar with retrieving
puzzle pieces from this world on their computer.
But this time Adminto would need to move around some things
as well, specifically by moving the keys from the small
portal to the big one.
I don't know what happens next though.
I see.
And red!
Does Adminto know where these portals are?
You should probably ask Adminto on this.
Right.
Hold on.
It's glowing.
The journal is glowing again, Adminto.
Uh, oh.
Documents.
My games.
One shot.
Thank you.
Thanks.
I'm all ready.
Here, I'll even... I will just do that, yeah.
This one is red.
This one will be meant for me, then.
This one is blue.
That's mine, then.
This one is green.
That one's mine!
Okie dokie.
Let's let him take his place.
This one is configured to my code, I think.
And poipul.
Hello?
What the...
No, what am I supposed to do?
Hello?
Oh, dude, now I do the documents thing.
Okay, okay, okay.
Uh, whoops, wrong mouse.
There we go.
Oh!
Portal 1!
Whoa!
Key B.
Put me in the big portal.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
I have to put you...
Oh, okay, okay.
I get it in here.
Oh, big portal.
Put me in the big portal.
Oh, what's...
Portal 2?
Put me in the big portal.
It's so funny.
Put me...
Wait, do I do just the TXT?
I feel like that's it.
They said the TXT file, so...
Right?
If not, I'll just, you know.
Put me in the big portal.
Oh, they're gone!
Oh my gosh.
What about...
Oh, wait, I did the wrong one.
Oh, that's why.
I was like, hello?
Oh, whoops.
I'm breaking the game.
Thank you, guys.
Oh.
Oh, I made a door.
Whoa.
That was fun.
Hold on.
Put me in the big portal.
I made a doctor.
Oh.
Whoa.
Oh!
Everybody's here!
That was quite peculiar.
I'll say.
Hey, this is...
Papa's room.
Put me in the big portal.
It's so funny.
The world machine.
Little Miss Menhara.
It's a big book on the table.
Minto, I'm going to need you to put me in the big portal.
What if I just have a stream where I make TXT files of
everybody in chat and I move you all to the big portal?
Wait, I can do it right now.
I can do it right now.
Wait, how do I?
Hold on.
I don't know if anything will show up.
Wait, let me just...
What is it?
it note wait how do i search oh my gosh how do i search on
this thing uh notepad notepad don't go notepad where is it
lm and wait it goes from m to a to all how do i search
where's notepad do i not have notepad Wait.
Hold on, I'm going to do this.
Pin to taskbar.
I'm kind of a genius, guys.
Okay, here we go.
Whoops.
I'm kind of a genius.
Colonel, I need you to put me in the big portal.
Everybody can go into the big portal.
All right, ready for this?
Oh.
Oh, no!
I need to use...
Save us.
My games.
One shot.
Oh, I had to do it again.
Put me in the big portal.
Okay, we gotta finish the game, guys.
Sorry.
I did one for the bit.
Not me jumping out of bed to be put in the big portal.
Okay.
Okay, barn.
I have to use a separate mouse or separate, uh, what's the
word?
Keyboard for this.
Put you in the big portal.
Put me in Harvester.
Wait, how?
Wait, look at it.
Everybody.
Wait.
Save us, rub, put you in the big portal.
The three chosen.
What if I go back to the game and it's just covered in
squares?
They're like, no, too many on the big portal!
It's a stack of books.
Glass tea set on the table.
Tea does sound really nice right now.
Too bad there's no water in here.
Coat rack with scarf and a big jacket.
Shelf full of books.
Bullets and board full of lots of papers on it.
I'm in the big portal!
What do you see?
This portal ain't big enough for the two of us.
Pilot's helmet.
Cute.
I'll put everybody in.
Everybody, just think of this.
The big portal is my heart.
And all of you are in there.
Hop on in.
The portal's fine.
This big portal's not big enough.
Detailed drawing of a machine with lots of TV screens.
That's called a blueprint, Nico.
So that's what a blueprint is.
Sounds like a scam.
What are you talking about?
We should get out before you get a cardiac arrest.
Wait, it's a blueprint.
Wait, that's so cute.
It's a big photo.
Wait, no, it's a painting.
Hard to tell at first.
What is the three of them?
Wait, that's so cute.
This place contains a lot of memories.
I am grateful to see it again.
The room ahead doesn't really lead anywhere, but...
Adminto should still remember what to do here.
Wait, Addo?
This is my father's study.
It feels like he's still here, doesn't it?
Like he's still with us.
Yeah.
Oh!
This again?
The music is so melancholy.
It makes me sad.
But the engraving is not this big portal.
Give me no extra room whatsoever.
Say everything up.
Don't say that.
Okay, here we go.
The way it closed was like so small, like so short.
No, like smooth.
Oh, oh, oh, no, you're right.
Sorry, I meant to click this.
Scared me for a second.
You listened to, he heard me.
Nico!
It's me.
Adminto.
Whoa.
Whoa!
The music in here is awesome.
Where are we?
Oh, it's all the places!
Wow!
Oh, wow!
Oh, the people and everything.
Oh.
Meantos' big portal grew three sizes that day.
Whoa.
I don't need to go down, right?
Okay, okay.
Oh, it reminds me of Space Mountain, the music.
Oh,
here.
Oh, scary, scary.
I must confront myself.
Peep, peep, boop.
Nico!
Ah!
Relax.
Has anyone ever made the folders this game means read-only?
I wonder how much it freaks out if it can't access things.
Wait, that's too big, Gigabrian.
I'm just borrowing your reflection to talk to you.
you.
It's not like my physical form is good for that.
Why did you come here?
Can't you see?
The disruption, the squares!
They're closing in.
Nico, please.
Get out of here.
Let me meet my end in peace.
The squares are blocking my way too, you know.
Oh.
I... I'm sorry.
I... It's alright.
Should be in this place, Nico.
Is this the tower?
Part of it.
This is the center of the engine.
Whoa.
Inside my head, so to speak.
So this is the center of the world machine?
You know my original name.
Cute.
How?
Rue, Cedric, prototype.
They all told me bits and pieces.
I'm not even sure if I understand a lot of the stuff they
said.
No, me neither.
You and I are on the same page there, Nico.
I know what you're supposed to be.
I know why you had to be built.
And I know why I'm here.
They told you?
When?
Wait, you don't know about that?
But I thought you were the world.
Aren't you supposed to see everything?
No.
All this was outside of the protocol.
never supposed to happen the way it did or at all they kept
telling me to put them in the big portal
the story wasn't written into my protocol at all oh right
root told me something about how your creator had to alter
the code i think it was to connect some areas together so
that we could meet My creator, yes.
Adminto.
Listen to my creator.
One second.
My tab just, my YouTube tab just crashed.
One moment, please.
Oh.
Don't say me, don't you, duh.
Hello, everybody.
I'm back.
we got put into the portal if you're bad you know how Kiara
has the usual room I'm gonna put you guys in the big portal
hey don't go acting up now you need to get put into the big
portal
it's a punishment no no no I never said that
they were all working beyond my scope of influence Minty
gotta put a toilet in the big portal.
I gotta go real bad.
Sorry, I can't understand you.
It's all binary.
You think you're writing text, but it's actually just zeros
and ones.
What did you say?
I can't understand your accent.
Back in the mind.
Sorry.
Back in the mines, I remember.
Oh no, the world machine yearns for the mines.
Had Minto did something to find a hidden map.
I did not even recognize it.
Don't send me back, I just got reformed.
Yeah.
You don't want to go back?
Are you sure?
Are you positive?
Make a toilet.txt and put it in the big portal.
Uh...
Wait, oops.
Let's see.
You guys asked for a toilet, but I can't restock it.
A potato should work just fine.
It's better than nothing.
How am I gonna dry?
Just spread the cheeks!
And like, wait.
A couple minutes.
Now you're thinking with the big portal.
Okay, back to emotional moment.
Back to emotional moment.
I couldn't see anything there.
I just knew what you were feeling.
You were really upset.
Something happened in there to make you upset.
After that, I...
I panicked.
That was when the caven happened.
I remember the structure collapsing.
I thought you got hurt, I...
In that moment, I really thought I was shutting myself down
for good.
I really am a flawed machine, aren't I?
My machine is so manhira!
You guys can stay in there.
What kind of machine would go against the wishes of its own
creator?
What kind of a machine would...
I'm...
The squares.
Rude told me it was your own code going bad.
But that's not really your fault, is it?
Yes, it was.
At first, it was intentional.
During testing, long before you realized I was self-aware.
I would rearrange specific parts of the code, jumbling up
bits and pieces of the landscape.
Oh, my God.
Dude, that's evil.
We're feeling some kind of emotion at this moment.
Blocking passages, collapsing catwalks.
Though they were very localized, it caused my creator a
great deal of frustration.
Rearrange my code So we're back in the mines Got our portal
swinging from Big to big Big, big to big Thank you for the
super time Forcing him to exit and restart testing Again and
again Why would you do that?
I got curious I just thought you would figure it out
eventually But before you knew how to fix it The world's
NPCs, the characters...
Some of them got too close and...
spiraled out of control after that.
I couldn't contain it at all.
My panic only made it worse.
Eventually any character who gained the knowledge of who I
am...
Their code, my code, couldn't handle it.
Previous iterations of the world had more people, you know.
And I almost endangered my creator too.
I... I was... I was so scared, Nico!
I know.
You're upset.
Because you don't want to put living people in danger.
Living people like me.
In the beginning, I tried to fight them.
Sorry for it.
My core programming made me summon you here.
Just trying to lighten the mood a little.
Sorry.
very serious serious serious here I'm from I'll show you how
serious I can't even laugh I can't smile
I tried to send you back home at the tower but it did not
work then I wanted you to break the sun I thought that would
have worked but I had no way to be sure but Anmento brought
you back anyway Nico All I want is for you to wake up back
in your world.
But I don't think I can make it happen.
But I know I can't go back home without saving the world for
real.
Which means we have to fix the root of the problem.
Oh my god.
Nico, you're like 10 years old.
You're not a therapist.
We have to fix you.
I can fix her.
What that's...
I know the original ending your creator put in was a happy
one.
Do you remember what it was supposed to be?
It's far too late for that.
That part of my code has been long corrupted.
That's okay.
I would still like to know.
Alright.
You were supposed to place the sun at the summit.
And then credits would scroll.
Credits?
And then you would return to the room you woke up in.
That's where you would have been able to leave.
And why is it that you can't do it now?
Nico.
The code's gone, remember?
Shattering the sun was only supposed to be a workaround.
Are they gonna make me cold?
That will make me cry for real.
I mean, these are real tears.
As you can see.
You see?
They're real tears.
Real.
I'm sad.
Real, real tears.
I don't even remember the original code enough to describe.
But at the same time, it...
Oh, I don't know.
Sounds like you're always fighting yourself.
Well, real.
Genuine crocodile tears.
No, they're real.
I could not produce this much... this much tear.
Unless I was really sad.
You can tell, huh?
thing about conflicts in your code isn't it i'm a machine
nico machines are built with a fundamental law which is
never let a living being come to harm you knew my very
existence conflicts with that law the life of a living being
like you is so unique so precious this fake world isn't
worth that risk the big portal changed her it's because i
never got to go into the big portal
If I learn how to code, I'll get a big fancy job.
Be a coder.
I'm gonna start hacking and helping with heists.
This fake world isn't worth that risk.
But, the people here, I think they are!
They are code too, you know this.
arrive from a predetermined matrix of actions.
Can you share the money with us?
Hackler Minky.
That will be me.
All extensions of my programming.
They cannot act outside of it.
You, though.
You're the only person who's actually real here.
That's why.
It's pointless to put you in danger to save them.
To save me.
I don't think that's true.
people I know you said this session wasn't in your code
right yeah so if the session wasn't supposed to happen even
if even you didn't know what to do how would the characters
how did the people know how to respond that's a good point
hacking to the gate sad singing
You said it yourself, when you didn't know what was
happening, you just kind of stopped working for a while.
So how did the people know what to do to help me to get
here?
Even if it meant getting hurt themselves.
Even if it meant messing up their own code.
You might not think they are real, but there must be
something real in them.
And if they're all supposed to be extensions of your code,
then there must be more to your own programming than you.
you know to can you try to put me through the ending when
you described daru my husband oh i love daru i like how
patient the squares are i know whereas it's truly an anime
moment where you're just the the baddie is powering up but
you're just chatting with somebody It's like the fastest
chat ever, but they're slowing down.
Like, in real time, it would be like, but in the show, they
slow it so that you can hear the full conversation.
I can still stick out my tongue.
How many times do I have to say this?
That code is gone!
It's all squares now!
No, not squares.
I'll just put you in danger I'll risk it I remember Rue said
the world was never designed to put me in danger Your
creator wouldn't want that And I trust you too Even if your
code is broken You can still go outside that code, right?
The computer learns how to code itself I can't tamed yes you
are you talk just like the tamed robots i know the robot
lady prototype taming is when a real person cares about you
right it's when a real person thinks you're real too right
well guess what i do and i know adaminto does too even
though you told them they only had one chance they found a
way back didn't they why did you think adaminto would keep
coming back.
Why do you think Adminto would restart even after the
ending?
Yeah.
Because I want the good ending.
I think Adminto wants to save the both of us.
So please, give me a chance.
I...
I don't know.
I've never done this before.
I'm scared.
You can do it.
I know you can.
You've helped me come this far.
Well, I don't think they've helped much, But, uh, I'll try.
I can't promise anything, but here, take the sun.
Whoa, how'd they do that?
I'll try to remember the lost code.
And recreate it.
But for that to happen, Nico, you need to navigate through
this room.
You need to get past the square somehow.
Oh, I don't like this.
What if you get hurt?
It's fine, it's fine.
I'll try to be careful, okay?
I can do this.
Oh.
Hey.
And Minto, did you see that?
The square is just...
Oh, I could just walk forward.
It just happened again.
I think something is making them go away.
Come on, let's try the rest.
Let's go.
Admin, though, I think it's working.
Nico was right.
I might actually be tamed after all.
I...
I remembered what the code was supposed to be.
Only bits and pieces, but I can remember.
And I'm trying to fill in the blanks, too.
And I'm restoring the original ending as we speak.
Let's go!
Nico will be able to reach the tower, summon at the end of
the credits!
After replacing the sun, Nico will go back to where it all
began.
And then Nico will be able to go home!
This is permanent.
After Nico wakes up back home, the world would only exist as
a memory.
For Nico, a dream.
Like thousands of other dreams.
For you, a story.
What?
Like thousands of other stories.
Why did that make me tear up for real?
But as long as Nico remembers this place, as long as you
remember this place, it'll be alright.
I was able to restore some other elements too.
The characters, the people that were lost on Nico's journey.
They're all in the next room!
I would have put them back where they belong, but...
Not yet.
I think Nico should see them again first.
This is so sad.
Please say goodbye to Nico for me.
Ah!
Messiah.
Robot lady!
You're okay.
I think so.
The music!
The last thing I remember was the squares closing in on me.
But then I ended up here unscathed.
soul.
This is such a strange room.
We can't be in the tower, can we?
I'm actually not sure myself.
Where did you come from anyway?
The room where the world machine was.
I think the world machine is trying to remember now.
The code that went bad.
I think it's restoring it all.
That must have been why the squares were going away,
Adminto.
And it's why you're here, Miss.
I think the world machine was able to recover your code too.
World machine, huh?
I'm not sure if I should tell you this, but what's that in
the distance?
It looks like a few more people are showing up.
Whoa!
Are they people you know?
It's a bit too far to tell.
Come on, Edminto, let's take a closer look.
It's...
This is so cute.
No!
We made it!
Meantobot made it!
Hi.
Oh, yeah.
I guess there's no water here.
It's fine.
The head engineer can help me later.
Oh, okay.
That's all we say.
Maze.
Hello, Messiah.
Plant lady, but I thought you...
I thought you...
It wasn't even squares that did that.
No.
I just...
wanted to see you both again.
I just wanted to say thank you.
Even this guy.
Off you go, Messiah.
Did you guys just get here?
I think so.
The square started multiplying around the island after you
guys left.
It was so freaky.
I fell right.
Wait.
I fell right into a bunch of them!
Callimus tried to save me and then...
We both ended up in this room.
Biggest scare of my life for sure.
Oh.
Say, what is this place?
Are we in Limbu?
Limbu!
Alula.
We're not dead.
Wait, are we?
Good.
Question.
Hey, Edminto, are they gonna be okay?
They're fine, Nico.
Everyone is fine.
The world machine.
We'll send them home soon.
Oh.
Well, Admin...
Admin says you're not dead.
We're in Limbo.
Phew.
They also said you'll be able to go back to your home very
soon.
That's even better than Limbo.
I guess you're leaving us now?
We're glad we met you, Nico.
Same.
Wait, can I talk to everybody again?
Oh, okay.
the big portal.
Off you go, Messiah.
It's you.
Glad to see you in...
One piece.
Glad to see you.
You're okay, too.
After this whole elevator thing.
That was, uh...
That was the most awkward elevator ride I've been through.
Talk to Silver again?
Okay.
By awkward, I meant.
I mean terrible, bad, awful, the absolute worst.
The squares, like, started leaking into the room, right?
And I was trapped like a rat.
And they just kept filling in the room faster.
Oh, my God, that sounds like drowning.
That's terrifying.
No, no, you're fine.
Everyone in this room is fine.
You'll all be able to go back home soon.
Oh, thank goodness gracious.
I can't work when I'm dead.
Let's go check.
Let's go check a Minto bot one more time.
And silver.
Oh, wait.
Off you go now.
The head engineer can help me.
Do not worry.
She's just walking around.
So, um, you...
Silver.
I don't believe I ever actually properly introduced myself.
The wage keeps thinking about his cagey.
Not the wagey cagey.
Sorry for that.
It's fine.
I'm Nico, by the way.
It's nice to meet you.
Nice to meet you, too.
Off you go now.
Aww.
Thanks, Liz.
This is Protobot.
Who are all these people in the big portal?
I thought there were only supposed to be three of us.
It's a portal, not an inn.
They're looking at me.
That's so cute.
Oh, they're looking at me.
Looks like you managed to do it!
You managed to tame the world machine, Nico.
I feel like the world machine has been tamed this whole
time.
Just by Edminto and I being here.
We did spend a lot of time here, after all.
Both of us never really stopped believing in this world.
The world machine just needed to realize that, I guess.
That sounds like a possibility.
or not.
Well, just throwing that idea out there.
This path leads to the summit of the tower.
You already know what to expect, right?
Mm-hmm.
It's the classroom, right?
That's it.
You can go through this portal when you are ready.
Well, goodbye, Nico.
In the end, the world machine was starting to create its own
code.
Going above and beyond its programming, not as the...
result of an error, but as a conscious choice on the part of
the machine.
Being able to generate its own path forward.
That's what being tamed is all about.
I couldn't have said it better myself.
Thank you for everything, Nico.
We'll miss you.
Adminto.
Nico, you're forever in your debt.
I'm glad we could help.
Alright, guys.
You're ready?
Music's so sad.
This is where the sun belongs.
Here goes nothing, Adminto.
Nah.
Whoa!
It's all disappearing.
Five!
Good job, Adminto and Nico.
Thank you!
Whoa!
He's home!
They're all home!
They're all home.
So cute.
Silver.
Yay!
So cute.
Love Prophet Bar is so cute.
Mito Bar is saved!
This is it.
We're back at the room that ended before, but we didn't
appear.
This is the room I first woke up in.
Adminto, are you still there?
Adminto?
Yes?
Adminto!
So cute.
I think... I think it worked.
It did.
The sun is back.
I actually got to see it this time, so...
We actually did it.
So, what do we do now?
I guess we should figure out how to get home from here.
This isn't the door, is it?
Looks like one of those portals we saw all the way back in
the city.
In the room behind the big clock.
And I see a wheat field on the other side!
I see my village.
I hear my mama.
She's looking for me.
Ah, Admento.
This isn't the first time we've said goodbye, is it?
But this is the last time!
I think
we'll ever see each other again after this!
And what will become of the world.
After all, we've been through.
After everything we've done.
I still don't know.
This place.
These people won't stop existing.
They'll be in your memory.
They'll be in my memory too!
I...
Promise I'll never forget this world!
I promise I'll never forget you, Adminto!
So take care of yourself, okay?
You too!
Goodbye, Nico.
I don't control him anymore.
Goodbye, Admin Toll.
Crazy!
That was crazy.
Thanks for playing my favorite indie, Admin Toll.
Of course, thank you.
That was crazy.
How did he do that?
Okay, good, everybody's still there.
I don't see anything changed, but...
Congrats on finishing the gaming though!
I love the final parts on this route.
The part where Nico walks off screen and goes to go home is
super cool.
Right!
Holy cow!
Thank you, Arigato.
Celebrate!
Oh my gosh!
Thank you for the to-do.
The concept of taming in this game comes from the story
Little Prince highly recommend.
Oh yeah!
That hurt you feel at the end is proof that the characters
are tamed.
When a fox becomes my fox, that's when it happens.
Thank you for this stream, my ghost.
Don't say that.
It's too sad.
The music is so nice.
I don't want to close it.
It's so nice.
But I guess I have to.
Where did he come from?
That's so wild.
I feel like I should have put it all the way up here, give
him a little bit of a walk, a stroll.
How did he do that?
That's crazy.
Let's try.
You cannot perform this action during cutscenes.
Wait, what?
Oh, it closed itself.
Okay.
I love this game so much.
Thanks for playing.
Thank you, Seymour!
X-Ray, thank you.
Let's open it one more time.
Oh, wait, there was a thing at the bottom.
But steam is blocking it.
Oh, wait, it's gone.
It was a dot, dot, dot.
I'm Minto.
You're back.
I restored the world.
I sent Nico home.
Are you not happy?
Even if he wanted to see Nico again.
You can't, I'm Minto.
Nico's gone.
Wait, what?
Wait, did you not know this was a scene?
Without Nico, there's no story for me to tell.
No Messiah to traverse across the land.
No way for you to connect with the world.
But Nico still remembers this place.
If you really want to see this world again, I could still...
Oh, but it won't be the same.
It'll just be a recording.
It'll just be me using Nico's memories.
It's like how I'm using Nico's reflection now.
Is that what you want?
No, I don't think so.
Vod watching.
No, I don't think I want that.
Our journey is over.
I see.
If you change your mind, though, feel free to come back.
It's not like I'm going anywhere.
Wow.
Wow!
Yeah, see, it's there and then it disappeared for some
reason.
I don't know why.
My game glitched or something.
If I star, what happens, I wonder?
Oh, it brings us back here!
What again makes you think, what if this world is a
simulation?
Well, if it is, we're just happy to share it with you.
I'd mean to...
Just know we'll always put you in the big portal in our
hearts.
Thank you for the stream.
Thank you, Dorgo.
I'm so bad with games.
Or not, I'm sorry.
Not, like, or rather things that make me have to say
goodbye.
You know, I'm so sad about that.
I'm not good at goodbyes at all.
So I always cry.
I'm like,
I'm not good with those kinds of things.
Blue, thank you.
First time we said goodbye, but this will be the last time.
It's so sad tonight, we're...
I know!
It's so...
Thank you for the mean down, down, though.
If this is a simulation, put me in the big portal.
We're all just...
We're all just little creatures in the big portal, huh?
Dark Sun, welcome back.
Thank you.
Having the Clover translator from Solstice in the base one
makes the plot even slightly different.
It is the hardest thing to go back through, though, because,
well, like, because you have to do everything over again,
or...
Hmm.
Yeah, I didn't expect the ending to give me so much, though.
But it was the good ending.
In the end.
Even if we had to say goodbye.
It was still good.
Spike, thank you for the...
Super Chat, thank you!
Thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you.
I think it's sadder to not get to say goodbye.
I agree.
I'm squishy.
What does that mean?
Oh.
We saved the world and sent him home.
That's exactly what we said we were going to do.
We're going to save Nico and save the world.
We did both.
But it is kind of sad when having to say goodbye to people
but you know i that's always what gets me about like ending
a game series you know like when you play a long series of
games i'm sorry i'm talking about metal gear again but you
know when you like play metal when you play metal gear no
when you play a really long series and then you finally get
to the end and you're just like ah it's like the ending of
an anime you know and you're just like oh man i don't know
but i you Even, I don't feel the same when I watch something
versus when I play something.
Because when I play something, I really feel like I become
the character.
Watching something, it's like a...
I'm watching for like a different POV.
But...
When I play something and I become so immersed, like I'm the
one moving the character.
I'm the one putting in the work.
It's so...
Yeah, you're in it.
Yeah.
So when you finish a really long game or something, and
you've put in so many hours and so much time, and you're
just like, man, I'm finally done.
Tearful goodbyes aren't our style.
After all, it'll be embarrassing when we meet again.
Hard in practice, though.
Even though New Year's passed, this was a nice way to end
the year.
Thanks a lot, man.
Yeah, I wish I could have done it before the new year,
right?
But it's also a good, maybe, reminder that goodbyes will
happen, but that our memories stay with us.
Our memories and our journeys stay with us and help us
create new memories and new journeys.
Yes, yes, yes.
Our memes live on!
I learned that in MLP.
Wait, who was your...
Who was your pony?
Pony Oshi.
Orca.
Does this count towards...
Wait.
Does this count towards last year or this year's game goal?
Well, I'm not doing a game goal this year, so...
You know.
We take it all and we put it in the big portal.
Nucky game marathon this year.
Oh my gosh.
What other Nucky game could we do?
Not that puppy game though.
See how the first playthrough isn't really beating it.
Yeah, 100%.
Oh my gosh, Vivi, happy birthday.
Thanks for throwing it off.
It's a happy puppy birthday.
Happy birthday.
Apparently, Orca likes Fluttershy.
Fluttershy.
The puppy game beckons you with promise of content.
I didn't watch the stream, but I saw someone clip a Bijou,
like, crying about the game, and I'm like, I was already
warned about this game.
Would you like to see how hard you can cry?
I think I cry.
hold back usually in these kinds of like I could have cried
way more for this game I think I try to hold back I I think
the most I've ever cried was MGS4 on stream that is the most
I've ever cried for a game I think goodbyes are important I
would give a lot to say goodbye to my late sister no
that's just Life though, maybe.
I think about my dad a lot at this time of the year, so...
It always makes me...
Because it was around this time that he passed, so...
I always get really...
It's a tough time of the year for me.
Sorry.
Oh.
Man.
Why is that comment that got me so bad?
It's the sad game music.
Yeah, we need to quit this game.
Sorry for being a crybaby
But I'm glad my papa is not a ghost Because I mean he has
unfinished business like me So I guess it's one of those
silver linings a little
I'm sorry, I lost.
I mean, it's just part of life and afterlife, losing people.
So, I'm sorry to everybody who's lost somebody too.
It doesn't get easier, but, you know, we can at least take,
we can, we can, we can distract ourselves with fun things
and the people that are.
still in our lives and after lives so
what a depressing what a depressing first stream of the year
it's cleansing are we all crying together first cry of the
new year
Thank you for sharing your time with us and trusting us with
your emotions.
They're there for us, and we're glad you let us do the same
for you.
Yeah, of course.
Of course, of course.
Mickey's already dead, which is why she can haunt us
forever.
Yeah!
I'll be haunting.
It was one.
No!
Oh, Blade Runner was so funny.
Oh, man.
I'll never regret becoming a streamer.
There's just so many good memories.
So many fun moments.
Yeah.
One, but a good one.
The dog freaking exploded.
It's so, oh god, I love when, I love when games are stupid.
Oh, I love it so much.
Oh gosh, it's like probably the funniest animal death I've
ever seen.
It's important to remember what came before.
It made us who we are.
as we go forward.
It's really proper for the start of the year.
Yeah, I feel like, right?
Oh my gosh.
I guess this was like a good kind of a good new year's game
after all, maybe.
It's been one year since I went to my friend Vito's funeral.
No, Jeff.
I love Hatsune Miku so much and adamantly against VTubers.
Oh no!
I showed him our world just before he passed.
I won't tell you, don't cry because not all the tears are
bad.
Genuine proofs of our feelings.
I have many feelings.
I have so many feelings.
That's what a ghost is, technically.
It's just a ball of feelings.
Intense feelings make me a ghost.
Miserable little pile of feelings?
Yes, Dracula.
My mom and dad passed in the last year and a half.
Oh my gosh.
WC, I'm so sorry.
I know she's very much including you.
I've helped me keep it together through that.
It really is.
it really just goes to show everybody's kind of dealing with
their own things in life and I'll try to be a little kinder
to people and to yourselves
that should be your new year's resolution and also your life
resolution is to be kinder to others and yourself yes yes
yes yes yes yes yes yes Yeah.
And with that, I will leave it.
We can...
Wait, I'm gonna put on some funny music.
Let's get us out of the...
Let's restart.
Oh, wait.
I'm in the cutscene.
I'm gonna put on some funny music.
I got this.
I got this, guys!
We'll cleanse it!
Wait, where is it?
Yeah!
Happy New Year!
Wait, you don't even have to do the YouTube bar to me.
What's up, everybody!
Thank you!
Have a good day, have a good night!
Take care of yourselves, okay?
Promise me that, alright?
Bye bye!
Bye-bye!
Oh,
I can't believe I have listened to this song enough times
that I know it.
Oh, no!